(slow rhythmic music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [DRock] What?
- I said, but I can
definitely tell you this,
DRock's a big idiot. (laughs)
(DRock laughs)
(slow electronic music)
You got your perspective.
(audience cheers)
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
(slow music)
- Hi, welcome to The
Leaders of Learning Podcast,
I'm your host, Ling Ling.
Joining us is a very
special guest, Gary Vee.
Gary Vee is a serial
entrepreneur, investor,
a New York Times' bestseller,
what else am I missing, Gary?
- Those were all plenty, thank you.
- A whole bunch of stuff.
- Thanks, Ling Ling, it's good to see you.
- And all around, a really cool guy.
- Thank you.
- If you don't know him
already, please listen
to this podcast episode, so
I've become an entrepreneur
about two years ago, a
little baby compared to you,
and of course it's a rollercoaster ride,
as being an entrepreneur.
And I believe a lot of my
listeners are also interested,
or thinking about
starting their own thing,
so I thought maybe I could take this time
to help my listeners try to figure out--
- Let's do it.
- How they start.
So one of my questions
I have is, you know,
what is the biggest thing you struggled
with most as an entrepreneur?
- Not being able to be one.
You know--
- What does that mean?
- That means that the first 12 years
of my school career were
genuinely, and I mean this,
the day I left college to go
work in my dad's liquor store,
and really run it, at that point,
because I'd grown up
in that store was the,
I can remember almost
everything about my last day
in college, driving down
Route 95 from Boston
to New Jersey, and that afternoon,
at, like, 6:13, pulling up,
it's funny that I am that
specific with my time,
but I remember looking at the car clock.
I spent an hour working in
the store before we went home,
and that's, like, literally
how my career started.
Like, I loved it so
much that after driving
for seven hours, 'cause there
was a lot of traffic that day,
from college, that I
wanted to work an hour
in the liquor store to,
like, start my career.
So the hardest thing for me,
and there's a very specific
reason I'm saying this
to everybody, the hardest thing for me,
being an entrepreneur, has been not much
because it is truly, truly my place.
And I do believe that
self-awareness is very important,
and so it's hard for me to
think about the negativities
of entrepreneurship, because
I just genuinely love it
so much, I love when I lose a client,
I love when somebody quits,
I love when somebody steals
from me, and I know this sounds weird.
And obviously I don't love
when somebody steals from me,
but I'm so grateful to genuinely be doing
what I was meant to do,
that it's hard for me
to get going, and, look,
entrepreneurship is lonely.
And I think a lot of
people, I always wonder,
I think people are a scale,
from zero to 100, in everything.
Singing, looks, humor, patience,
I think we go from zero to 100.
I think when it comes to entrepreneurship,
I really genuinely think I'm 100.
I struggle with any of the negativities.
You know, I say that
entrepreneurship is lonely,
'cause it is, but I like being lonely.
I like being on a 17 hour
flight, like I was today,
and thinking for two, three
hours about only negative stuff,
stuff that most people don't
want to be thinking about,
this problem, that problem.
So that's my story.
- Yeah.
I absolutely agree with
you about being very lonely
in the entrepreneurial journey
because everyone has their own ideas,
they want to execute it, but to get people
to follow along with you is not as easy.
So if any of our listeners would like
to start their own business,
or become an entrepreneur,
what are the key things they need
to consider first before
they embark on that journey?
- Right now, entrepreneurship
is cool, it's flashy,
it's exciting, and so the
first thing I think they need
to think about is, look, if
you're looking to sign up
for this, rest assure that the first five
to six years are gonna suck.
They're gonna be lonely,
they're gonna be difficult.
What has made it less suck is,
there's so much capital
being thrown at people.
So this is, the reason
there's so many people
in entrepreneurship
today is, it's very easy,
and I'm gonna use that, it's
easy to raise a million dollars
for your idea now, not the
case when I was growing up,
not the case after the
economy's gonna collapse
inevitably at some point.
So what's happening is
people are getting tricked,
'cause they're raising capital,
and they think they're doing well,
but they're burning
cash, and the reality is,
they're only in fundraising
mode at all times.
And so, A, if they're thinking about it,
recognize that if you're fortunate enough
to be in a family, in a situation
that's gonna allow you to raise capital,
recognize that that is most likely going
to be your vulnerability, it's
gonna be feel good up front,
but on the backend, it's
gonna be your vulnerability.
And for the people who are listening
that don't have the
luxury of raising capital,
recognize that you have an advantage.
You're gonna be forced
to actually make money.
And one of the things
I'm most proud of is,
the two businesses that I've run,
you know, there was no capital infusion.
There wasn't a credit
line, or raising capital
to build WineLibrary.com,
but there was a foundation
of the business that my dad have.
But VaynerMedia started in
a conference room like this,
with no capital, and I was always forced
to make money, and I think
for anybody who's listening,
instead of thinking about raising capital,
you know, why don't you
try to figure out how
to make money, but if that's the case,
recognize it's gonna take a half decade
of a lot of grinding.
- Yeah, I remember listening
to a talk somewhere,
one of the local entrepreneurs
said the best money
to earn is the money from your clients,
and not from your investors,
and that kind of just blew my mind away.
It's like, oh, yeah, that's really true,
'cause in a way, it's a
validation from clients, right?
If they're willing to pay
for your services or product.
- Oh, gosh, I mean, I couldn't agree more
with whoever said that, I mean, to me,
this will be known as the great era
of people building financial
arbitrage machines,
not companies, people are building decks,
and taking meetings with BCs all day,
they're not worried about their product.
I mean, I don't know what else to say,
like, I mean, I just,
there's an enormous amount
of bad companies in the world today,
because there's so much capital.
And that will eventually go away.
- Indeed, you mentioned earlier about,
the biggest challenge is
not being an entrepreneur.
Do you believe it's,
entrepreneur is something
that you're born with, passionate,
or is it something that can be learned?
And if it can be learned, what are the
characteristics of an entrepreneur
that can make them successful?
- I believe that
entrepreneurship is similar
to dancing and singing and
playing ping pong and basketball.
What that means is, it can be taught.
The problem is, being a
successful entrepreneur means
that you how to be good.
- What does that mean, good?
- Good means you need
to be able to sustain,
and make money, and
not go out of business,
and I don't think everybody
is capable of that.
- Okay.
- I don't think that, you know,
most people are not capable
of getting paid to sing,
forget about being Beyonce,
or Lady Gaga, I mean, can
you make money singing
on a cruise ship, or in a
bar, or playing local pubs
to sustain your lifestyle?
It's difficult, and I think
most people are not capable
of building an entrepreneurial business
that sustains their life.
- But it also sounds like, to
be a successful entrepreneur,
you need to be first and
foremost a salesperson,
and not just, or singing, or dancing,
'cause people who are singing or dancing,
they love doing that, right?
- Yeah.
- But to get money, you need
to have sales skills, no?
- Yeah, yes, I mean, you know, obviously,
generating revenue is part of it, and so,
and there are a lot of
people who are not capable
of selling, however, she or he can partner
with a salesperson, or
hire one, and, you know,
and, you know, if you're
the greatest maker
of putting in the world,
and you're gonna have the
best product in the world,
and you have a secret recipe
from your grandmother,
and you're a hustler, and
you want to make a pudding,
but you're petrified to
sell to people, you partner
with somebody, or you hire
somebody after you raise capital,
or start selling a little bit at first.
So yes, I do think that a singular person,
if they have no partnerships
in the beginning,
needs to understand how
to generate revenue.
I think these things are teachable,
but I think people need to
know that they have a ceiling,
'cause entrepreneurship is a skill,
and in any skill, we have a ceiling.
I can become a much
better painter tomorrow
than I am today, I just don't think
I'm going to be an all-time painter.
- Okay, so it's just understanding
and recognizing one's own limits
on how much you want to do?
- And you know what's
funny, it's not that I want
to contain things into limits,
it's that I want people
to start realizing
entrepreneurship is a talent.
Everybody just thinks,
like, you say you're one,
and away you go, and they would never do
that with being a professional skier,
or a professional three star chef.
But for some reason, the
nature of business is
so inclusive, which is
amazing, the problem is,
it got so cool that now
we have a whole generation
of people who are forcing themselves
to be entrepreneurs to fit
in that just don't have it.
And that's gonna lead
to a very scary place,
because what's very amazing
about entrepreneurship is
that it's inclusive,
what's very devastating
about entrepreneurship
is it's not forgiving.
- Why isn't it forgiving?
- Because when you lose,
you're out of business,
and everybody knows, you
know, your parents know,
the world knows, and you've failed.
And that is tough, because when
you're not an entrepreneur,
failure is scary.
- Yeah.
- And so that framework
leads to depression
and unhappiness, and that needs to be
of the ambition of human beings,
and so I'm a little bit worried
that we've over-corrected.
I'm thrilled that
entrepreneurship is now viable,
and it's not just, go to
college and get a job.
I'm a little concerned
that we've over-corrected,
and we have a great generation
of people who are not prepared
for the ultimate loss
of public humiliation,
because they're talking a big game now,
I'm gonna build a big
company, di di di di di di di,
and when it fails, it's gonna hurt.
- Some people, they are so ingrained
in the idea of, my idea
of being a business
and an entrepreneur, and
they think it's really big,
it's gonna change the world, but how would
you know if you're ready
for the big humiliation
that you're talking about?
'Cause some people are just so big
in their ego, I think my
idea is great and fantastic,
and they put a lot of effort in it, and--
- You know, I think anybody
who's listening right now,
if you want to set
yourself up for success,
ask yourself how much risk you've taken
in the first 10, 15, 20,
30, 40 years of your life.
Ask yourself how much
you've been succumbing
to peer pressure, like, if
you've always wanted to be cool
to the popular kids in your
high school, you're in trouble,
because that means you're
pandering to a system.
So, you know, I don't
know if anybody knows
what they're prepared for,
I think people are way more prepared
for things than they
realize, on the flip side.
But yeah, I mean, that's
the other thing right now.
We have these spectacular companies,
like Uber and Facebook, and WeChat,
and all these companies
that make everybody think
you have to make a game
changing, you know,
technology, or things of that nature.
The reality, though, is 99% of people
should
have aspirations to build a business
that does 500,000 a year in
revenue, not 500 trillion,
but everybody's trying to
build the next Instagram,
and I think that's going to be a problem.
- Yikes, yikes, that's so scary.
Well, talking about Instagram,
you're also of this social
media mogul globally.
What do you think, where
do you think Asia is going
when it comes to the
social media landscape?
Will we see more of the usual suspects,
like Facebook, or Instagram,
or shall we see something
a little bit more like
podcasting, for example?
- So Asia's an interesting spot, right,
because Mainland China, outside of Russia,
is really one of the few places at scale,
'cause obviously there's Line,
and there's other,
Toutiao, there's things,
but Mainland China is the one place,
WeChat, Weibo, that has massive
scale in social networks.
It's really been interesting for me
to watch Southeast Asia
adapt, US platforms adapt,
Chinese platforms, I actually
think Southeast Asia,
as a whole, is one of
the most dynamic places
for this conversation,
because they're influenced
by both sides,
more than anywhere else
I've seen in the world.
So,
you know, I view podcasting
as a medium in itself
that is slightly different
than the way we think
about social media, but
to your point, I do think
that social media has become
a broadcasting platform,
which is no different than podcasting.
Look, I think humans want to communicate,
and they always have, and so
whether it's written word,
audio, or video, that is
what we will always do.
And so I think cultural,
contextual nuances always play
throughout the world,
we've seen it in cuisine
and in fashion, and we will
see it in technology behaviors.
But I think the opportunity
has never been greater for human beings
to take advantage of
opportunities in front of them
because of the scale of these platforms.
And obviously, every
country has its own dynamics
of censorship, or,
you know, it's, I think
Americans are very naive.
They cast judgment on
places like China or Russia,
but we have our own
versions of it in America,
it just plays out differently.
And so there's a lot
of different sandboxes,
a lot of different opportunities.
Some places have more
opportunities than others,
some are rigged games more than others,
but the reality is, it's a special time.
- So just broadcast, use
whatever medium, depending on--
- Yeah, the good--
- What you want to do?
- The fun thing here is, look,
we don't have to predict the next medium,
we just need to properly
use the medium of today.
You know, a lot of people are like,
"Gary Vee, what's next,"
I'm like, I have no idea.
I've never, ever predicted anything,
I've just been the fastest
to move on everything.
- I see, I see.
So if,
if you could offer a first
time entrepreneur one piece
of advice, what would that be?
- Don't listen to a soul.
Don't listen to the positive, don't listen
to the negative, don't, you
listen to too much positive,
you become entitled and soft, you listen
to too much negative, you
become weak and scared.
Don't listen to anything,
listen to your consumer.
Not the headlines, not your
parents, just your consumer.
- Fantastic, Gary, thank you so much
for being on the show,
it's such a pleasure to--
- Thanks for having me.
- With us today, thank you.
- Thanks, Ling Ling.
- [DRock] Awesome.
- [Maha] That was great,
that was really good.
(DRock mumbles)
- Okay, cool, let me just--
- Yeah, make sure you got it.
- Make sure I got it.
- [DRock] Where's Gary
gonna go out tonight?
- [Maha] Yeah, well, he
has a phone interview
in four minutes, I'd rather
do it than do the meeting,
instead of, 'cause it's a journalist,
it'll take a couple of minute phone call,
instead of going out to do the--
- [DRock] Got it, and
then bounce back here?
- [Maha] And then bounce back,
so let's just have the call.
- Are you sending me the
information for the call?
- [Maha] We're just gonna do it, WhatsApp,
I'll just give you my phone.
- [Ling Ling] Okay.
- [Maha] Thank you.
- Thank you.
- [Ling Ling] That's all
right, I just heard--
- No problem.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Maha] We're just
talking about logistics.
- [DRock] You're fine.
- [Ling Ling] Cool,
cool, what did you think?
- [Maha] It was great,
it was really great.
- [Ling Ling] Did I get, did I--
- You were great.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Maha] Good questions,
they're gonna enjoy the answers,
too, I took good notes.
- [Ling Ling] Yay.
- [DRock] I was looking onto your notes,
pretty good notes.
- [Ling Ling] Oh, Nick
says hi, by the way.
- Awesome, thank you.
- [Ling Ling] Do you mind,
if we could get a photo--
- Let's do it.
- [Maha] I can take it, you don't have to.
(quiet overlapping chattering)
- [DRock] All right,
one, two, three, cool.
- [Ling Ling] All right--
- [Gary] Awesome, thank you.
- [Ling Ling] Thank you so much--
- [Gary] Thank you, so good to see you.
- [Ling Ling] Yeah, good to see you, too.
(quiet overlapping chattering)
Oh, he's looking away.
- Oh, let's do it again.
- [DRock] There's a few,
and there's a few in there.
- [Ling Ling] There's a few,
there's one looking away.
Oh, this one--
- There it is.
- [Gary] You're good, or?
- [Ling Ling] It's a bit fuzzy.
- [Gary] Let's do one more.
(quiet overlapping chattering)
(DRock mumbles)
- [DRock] All right, so one, two,
three, cool.
(Maha mumbles)
(overlapping chattering)
- [Maha] It's so nice with the background,
the green background.
- I know.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Ling Ling] I intentionally
put it here, so--
- So good.
(Ling Ling mumbles)
- [Ling Ling] Yeah, you're
looking at the camera now,
cool, thanks.
- You're welcome.
(quiet overlapping chattering)
- [DRock] You want me to
help you get this outside?
(overlapping chattering)
- [Maha] So Gary, this is an interview
for Empathy Wines--
- Yep.
- [Maha] Vino M-O-F-O, Mofo--
- Yep, Vinomofo, I know them.
- [Maha] They are having
a big event today,
and they have press, and so
they've asked us if we can do--
- [Ling Ling] Bye, thank you.
- Bye, so good to see you.
- [Maha] A couple times, we tried to do it
in New York, and it didn't work,
so we streamlined it up
just for a quick phone call.
She just wants to ask you a few questions
about Empathy Wines--
- You got it, let's rock and roll.
- [Maha] She's with The
Straits Times, yeah.
- [Martha] Hello?
- [Maha] Hello.
- [Martha] Hi, it's Martha.
- [Maha] Hi, how are you?
I'm gonna put you on the line
with Gary, I'm gonna take
you off the speaker so
it's clear, here's Gary.
- How are you?
I got in a couple hours, I
got in a couple hours ago.
And meetings and meetings,
and we're off and running.
Happy to do it.
- [Martha] Yeah. (mumbles)
- You know, it's something, you know,
I grew up in the wine business,
since I was 14 years old,
so I'm sure, you know, it's
always subconsciously been
in my mind, of, like, will
I ever have my own brand?
It started getting more
serious out of circumstances,
meaning, my two partners, John and Nate,
have worked for me and
with me for 10 years or so,
and it, you know, there was a crossroads
in their careers at VaynerMedia,
and the huge emergence of
direct-to-consumer brands,
as a trend that I was looking at.
And, you know, being out
of day-to-day wine business
for the last seven or
eight years, just a lot
of different things
happened that made me say,
hey, what would it look like
if I started my own brand?
And that's kind of how it started.
- [Martha] Okay. (mumbles)
- You know, John and Nate were easy
because they came to me as interns
when I was doing the wine business.
So they, you know, they were
there along the whole way.
It was just a very obvious transition,
when I decided to do it, you know, again,
I decided to do it because they had become
very strong executives
at VaynerMedia, and--
(Martha mumbles)
Oh, really?
No, no problem, I'm trying to,
huh, I'm not moving,
maybe I'm in a bad spot?
Maybe I'll just move
over here for a second.
How about now?
- [Martha] Yeah. (mumbles)
- Okay, so they were just easy,
you know, it was an easy decision,
because they were there the whole time.
And a lot of the reason
I started Empathy was
because of John and Nate.
So it wasn't difficult to
decide who the work with,
it was right in front of my face.
- [Martha] Yeah, I mean, I
think the wine. (mumbles)
- Oh, I apologize, that
was very, that was fun.
That was predicated on
tasting a lot of wine,
and figuring out which vineyards
were sourcing those wines,
and then going and meeting
with the vineyards,
and just deciding who
I had chemistry with,
and who I most enjoyed working with,
and who really clicked with us personally.
- [Martha] Okay, how did you. (mumbles)
- You know, we negotiated directly
with the vineyards, you
know, they're in the business
of selling grapes, so it wasn't hard
to convince them to work with us,
other than I wanted
more aggressive pricing
because I wanted to pass
that onto the consumer,
and position the brand
in the right price point.
So, you know, there was probably eight
or nine vineyards that we got down to,
and then we started doing
business negotiations,
and five to six emerged
of willing to do it
in the price points that we wanted.
And then we let the
growing season play out.
It was unfortunately a difficult year,
because there was some big fires,
so some of the people we were working
with had smoke issues, so that's just kind
of how we got down to our final partners.
- [Martha] Okay. (mumbles)
- No, no, it didn't delay the release,
it just, it eliminated
one farmer, specifically,
that I was pretty fond of, unfortunately,
they just had too much smoke damage.
- [Martha] Great, okay, so. (mumbles)
- Yep, that's the right word, you know,
that's the right word,
we're making 30,000 cases,
10,000 cases of each flavor,
red, white, and rosé.
- [Martha] Okay, but you chose. (mumbles)
- 'Cause it's ready the
soonest, so it's all
from the same vintage, and the release
of rosé, then white, then red
is completely predicated on,
you know, how long it
has to stay in barrel,
and which wines are ready the soonest,
and things of that nature.
- [Martha] Yeah, okay, and
what were you. (mumbles)
- The biggest thing I was
paying attention to was,
could we make it delicious, like,
I think people over-complicate
wine in the business,
they try to get too
nerdy, too complicated,
too scientific, too artistic.
I'm very basic, can I make
a wine that the person
that drinks it thinks
is downright delicious,
and wants to drink more of it.
- [Martha] Okay, and would it. (mumbles)
- You know, that's funny you say that.
There was thoughts I
had, that I want to use,
for example, for the rosé, I thought
I was gonna skew more towards
pinot noir and Grenache,
we ended up using more Syrah and Cinsaut.
So, you know, one of the
things I'm always trying
to be careful of is trying
to make decisions up front
that don't play out in reality.
So there's this series of
seven to 10 different grapes
that could have been used,
and then we just tasted
and blended, and then
wherever delicious came out,
we worked backwards, there was no emotion
to use more pinot noir and less, you know,
cabernet, you know, it was just,
what were the best
varietals, the best blend
of them to produce the style
of wine that we were looking to make.
- [Martha] Okay, and how involved were
you in the process? (mumbles)
- Oh, I basically made
the decisions, like,
I didn't want to put anybody, like,
I didn't want to put
anybody in a vulnerable spot
in year one, if it wasn't gonna work,
I didn't want to blame John,
or Nate, or anybody else.
So I was, you know, it's
funny, we have the footage
of the blending sessions.
I think people would be
flabbergasted how much
I was driving the boat, I have
a very distinct understanding
of what the consumer wants
to drink, and I definitely,
out of all the, out of all the things
that have been involved with Empathy,
the actual wine is probably the thing
that I've been most aggressive about.
Which makes me laugh because
I think the outside
perception is probably,
that's the thing I'm probably
least paying attention to,
and the business, and the marketing.
But the reality is, I
was very, very involved
in the wine itself.
- [Martha] Yeah. (mumbles)
- Yes, (laughs) yes.
(Martha mumbles)
Yes, for sure.
- [Martha] Yes, well, what do
you want people to. (mumbles)
- I want them to be
surprised how good it is,
honestly, that is my, you know, look,
when people drink wine,
they feel a lot of things,
either excitement, sorrow, I mean,
there's a lot of things
out of my control that,
when people are drinking wine.
What is in my control is
them being flabbergasted
and surprised by the
quality, and we did set out
to produce $40.00 to
$50.00 wine for $20.00.
That is a very big goal of mine,
and the feedback so far
has been remarkable,
and I think it's because the wine's
just been a lot better than
people thought it would be.
- [Martha] Okay, how much
have you moved already?
- I think the, I think maybe, let,
I want to, let's make sure
we give you the right number
because I don't want to
give it to you wrong,
but I think we're about 9,000
cases in, at this point.
I mean, the white and the
red aren't even out yet,
so there's only so much we can do.
- [Martha] How many did you say?
- 9,000.
- [Martha] 9,000?
- Mm-hmm.
(Martha mumbles)
So in the US, it's completely
100% direct-to-consumer,
but internationally, the cost
would have been too expensive
to ship individually, and since
I've known the Vinomofo guys
for a long time, I just felt
like I was comfortable making
that partnership, and we
took a pretty substantial,
you know, hit financially because we had
to still create the integrity of the price
for the end consumer.
So that's how we ended up
doing it in that scenario.
So to your point, it's
obviously direct-to-consumer
in the US, but it is not
direct-to-consumer internationally,
because we need a retail, or a
distribution kind of partner.
- [Martha] Okay, just wanted to check.
- Yeah.
- [Martha] And. (mumbles)
Yeah. (mumbles)
- For the wine?
(Martha mumbles)
It's--
It's 'cause Vinomofo had the capabilities,
and because I have an office
here, and I'm here a lot,
and so it's just a good market for me.
And so it was exciting to
be able to offer it here.
- [Martha] And when can
we expect the. (mumbles)
- The white comes out in a month,
and the red comes out
in September, October.
(Martha mumbles)
What's that?
- [Martha] Are you excited--
- Oh, very.
Very, I mean, I've been looking
forward to this for years,
so I'm very excited.
All right, they're grabbing me,
I have to run to this other
meeting, thank you so much.
- [Martha] You're welcome.
- All right, bye-bye.
- [Photographer] Oh, boy,
these chairs are really hard
to get out of--
- [Interviewer] So you don't
need me in the picture,
you need only the important
person here. (laughs)
- [Photographer] Yeah,
I think this should be--
- [Interviewer] All good?
- [Photographer] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Okay, all right, mate.
Should we, should we kick--
- Let's do it.
- [Interviewer] So let's start
with a bigger picture question.
Who are your industry heroes,
'cause you're an industry
hero to a lot of people,
who--
- Oh, boy.
This is gonna be a tough one, and so,
and I'll tell you why,
I don't like the answer,
but it's the honest answer,
the answer is really nobody.
And I feel like the
reason I don't like it is,
when I hear myself even say it,
there's a level of audacity,
but here's the truth.
I am a complete byproduct
of a very simple framework.
My parents are my heroes, and
the consumer is the only thing
I've ever spent my time on.
You know, I don't really read
a lot of book, any books,
I don't consume others, I'm,
I'm obsessed with
consuming, people consuming.
So, you know, I admire, or I
could go the other direction,
I admire anybody who is able to operate
and sustain a business, because
I know how difficult it is.
So,
but that is the truth, it's very ironic,
because I'm very aware
of, like, what I'm doing
with my own behavior,
and what it's manifested,
but I think a lot of that has to do
with how much I care
about the end consumer.
And so it's a little meta that way.
So please, let's make sure the tone
of that audacious answer is caught,
because I always struggle
with that question.
Even the last couple of years, I'm like,
man, maybe I should start, like,
paying attention to, but the truth is,
that is what I spend all my time on,
which is the end consumer.
And so the end consumer
is my hero, my obsession,
what I spend my time on.
- [Interviewer] Excellent,
okay, and let's talk
about Singapore, you got,
you're opening up your--
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] HQ here in
Singapore, so tell me, you know,
why Asia, why now, what's
going to be the focus,
in terms of geography, and
in terms of the products,
and the clients you're going for?
- So when I started
VaynerMedia, I had one mission,
which was to build a global
communications framework
in the form of a client service business,
to allow me to take advantage
of global economic downturns,
and to buy businesses and brands,
and then run them
through that machine, so.
Every single part of the world
isn't inevitable, you know,
the answer to why now is
far more circumstantial
because I want to be everywhere.
When and if and how we pop up
with offices is predicated
a little bit more
around casting, and in being intuitive,
and client dynamics, and opportunities.
So a perfect storm of
Avery and Jeff Nicholson,
a perfect storm of Risa,
who grew up in the area,
a perfect storm of me coming out
and doing some keynotes here
and building up profile,
a perfect storm of major
Fortune 500 clients
that we're servicing well
in London and the US asking,
like, hey, are you in the region?
Hiring a CFO who spent, you know,
five to seven years in the
region gave me confidence.
And then probably in the last half decade,
the very obvious nature of, okay,
Asia is, like, forever, like, this is it,
like, this is gonna be
a very major push, so.
Macro, inevitable,
micro, circumstance-ion.
- [Interviewer] Okay, so
it's not just pins in a map,
really, for you guys, but how
deeply will you, personally,
be involved in the Asia office?
I mean, you're a brand within
a brand yourself, right?
You're probably going to
have to be here fairly often
for it to make a bang in the
beginning, what's the plan?
- The plan is, every
eight to 12 weeks, so I don't
feel like I have to be here
that, that much.
I'd prefer to be here more.
But I'm giving you that answer
because I think that's
gonna be the actual truth,
instead of my ideology of every six weeks.
And so, you know, look, we
service Fortune 500 companies,
these are global companies,
so a lot of times,
decisions are being made in other places
that will impact our business here.
But I want to be here, in general,
as a human, I'm interested,
and there's so much going on.
So, you know,
I'm gonna be thoughtful about it,
and then obviously we think a lot about,
you know, I think a lot
about, what does this mean,
as a whole, for Mainland
China, Australia, Korea, Japan,
and so there's a lot of
dynamics playing out in my head.
And obviously I'm able to distribute
and create content all over the world
from wherever the heck I am.
We're filming this right
now, it will be consumed
in Europe, and Canada,
and South America, and so
that is the beauty of the internet.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
absolutely, and so no plans
to move to Singapore--
- Not personally, there's
only one place on earth
that I can live, New York City.
- [Interviewer] Near the Jets?
- Near the Jets, by the
way, that is incredible,
I am not joking, that
is the actual reason.
- [Interviewer] Is it? (laughs)
- That is the actual reason.
- [Interviewer] I thought
it might be, I saw the--
- It is the actual reason.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, yeah.
- I don't even want to, I don't even,
like, consider LA for
that reason, you know?
- [Interviewer] Got
you, okay, so let's talk
about what's next, you've done wine,
you've done marketing, or
you're doing marketing.
You're doing social media,
you've done book publishing.
What is next--
- I will be--
- [Interviewer] A TV show on Netflix?
I mean, where is it going?
- I will definitely be the CEO
of a consumer packaged good,
100%, I will buy a brand, it will happen.
- [Interviewer] Interesting.
- That is the, that is the
reason I set up the global,
you know, infrastructure,
is to buy a brand
and run it through that machine,
and when I do that, I
will promote somebody
from within to be the CEO of VaynerMedia,
and I will be the CEO of Snickers, or
Pellegrino Water, or a
deodorant, or a shampoo.
And it will be an iconic, known brand,
because otherwise, I would
have just started something
from scratch, I am unbelievably passionate
of taking a nostalgic
brand and rebooting it,
or, in the framework of
my international strategy,
taking a brand that is an
icon in Southeast Asia,
and introducing it to
the US, or vice versa.
And so a lot of why I want
to do this is, you know,
I'm very fascinated by that
crossover in a global world,
and that arbitrage.
And so that will definitely happen.
- [Interviewer] Okay, well,
that would be a completely
new model, I mean,
so I guess it's similar
to Samsung and Cheil,
but it is a new model.
I wanted to talk to you about new models--
- Please.
- [Interviewer] In the agency world,
given that Accenture has now bought--
- Droga.
- Droga5.
And where do, where do
you think it's going?
I mean, are you, do you
see a new model emerging,
or are you just out there
to create your own one?
- Yeah, I mean, you know, I don't really,
you know, I assume, and
this could be wrong,
'cause I haven't put a
lot of homework to it,
but, you know, Accenture
getting into the game so big,
and others, like, banks,
bigger versions of the banks
that have run this
industry seems inevitable,
so I look at these, you know,
these consultancy firms as
just WPP and Omnicom 2.0.
They have the same energy,
there's the same M&A strategy,
they're the same damn thing.
They're short-term economics, arbitrage,
which is amazing, and that's
fine, I have a lot of respect
for it, as a businessman,
for me, I'm trying
to build an evergreen
communications platform
to then run all my agendas
for the next five decades
through, whether that's political,
social, and definitely
business and financial.
And so I know that I'm
creating a very unique,
I almost look at what
we're doing in this time,
in the agency landscape, as the chess move
to what I'm actually doing.
So since it's not the place
that I'm really looking
to make my economics,
what has happened is,
and this is absolutely
true, on the record,
I've stumbled into,
this was no master plan,
I've stumbled into actually
being consumer-centric,
actually being aligned with my clients,
actually being in client services
because I'm not trying to
maximize my EBITDA off of them.
I'm trying to become them,
thus I'm testing my best work
with them, to then give me triple context
and confidence to do it for myself.
And so somehow, miraculously,
through serendipity
and karma, when you're
up to the right thing,
I think we're creating
a very unique concept
that I'm hopeful inspires copycats,
because I think it would be very healthy,
because I think we are absolutely living
through a very difficult
era, where the scrutiny
to agencies from brands
is very appropriate.
However, brands need to look at themselves
in the mirror and realize,
you get what you pay for.
You know, they continue to pick one, or,
they think moving from one holding company
to the other is gonna mean something.
And they've,
it just, it's a very,
it's a very, you know, I
compare it to what I saw,
I was an early investor in Uber.
I compare the current landscape
of the industry, similar to
the taxi business in New York.
There was, the taxi medallion
owners had a monopoly,
and thus, the consumers, us New Yorkers,
did not love the product
because there was a monopoly,
and it was just one bad ecosystem.
And then, you know, in, for, you know,
there's a lot of scrutiny on
Uber and Lyft and all that,
but for whatever it's worth,
I think everybody understands
that transportation is much
better in the globe today
because it led to scooter
innovation, and many other things.
And I think that's about
to happen in this industry.
I think the agencies aren't
happy, the clients aren't happy,
the employees of agencies
are extremely unhappy.
It's not healthy, and a couple
people made a lot of money,
and I think
I would be very grateful if we
were able to leave a legacy.
You know, it's very funny
we're having this conversation.
Today there was an article written,
I haven't done a Wine Library TV episode
in eight years, today, there
was an article written,
The Guy That Broke Wine, and
it was a very in-depth article
of what I did with Wine Library TV,
and how I changed that industry.
And it, and I was on this 17
hour flight, and I was like,
I'm gonna change the
advertising industry, too.
- [Interviewer] So if you
break advertising, what's,
what then is the end goal, is it,
is it an IPO, is it an exit, or?
- It is for it to be a standalone business
in perpetuity, I may
even, I may even write it
into my will, if I get
ideological enough about it.
- [Interviewer] So never going public?
- No, definitely not while I'm running it,
because I'm incapable
of being a public CEO.
I have no interest in prepping
for a call every 90 days.
(Gary laughs)
(interviewer laughs)
- [Interviewer] One more question, okay,
we'll make it count, so
let's talk about Instagram
and Facebook, and your
videos in the various guises.
Is that all brand building--
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] For you
and your companies, or?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] It is, or is
it giving back, or is it--
- Oh, yes.
- Entirely?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] How do you see that?
- Both.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- Yeah, I think, I think
you've got it clearly pegged.
It's an incredible opportunity
for me to leave a legacy,
by disproportionally bringing value.
There's a reason I've
become who I've become.
Very few people are trying
harder to actually bring value
to the end audience with no
expectation in return than me.
I've done that, you know, it's funny.
This is a very meta conversation.
The Gary Vee thing has a lot
to do with the same reason
I think VaynerMedia's gonna be a thing.
When you build an
infrastructure and a strategy
and a framework that
doesn't put you at odds
with your consumer, you win.
And it's very hard to do that in business.
- Especially if you have shareholders.
- Yes, and especially if
you're an Instagram influencer
who pays their rent based on them saying,
and now buy this, and now buy this,
and now buy this.
I've allowed myself to not monetize
from my audience, which
has made me more valuable
to my audience, so I am able
to leave legacy and give back.
At the same token,
which is why I was so transparent
in saying yes and yes.
Of course it builds
brand, people are humans.
Like, if somebody has
a 17-year-old daughter
that's gotten unbelievable value from me,
but they also happen to
be the CMO of a company,
that's gonna make them look at
me slightly different than if
I didn't bring value to
their 17-year-old daughter.
Not that that means that
they're gonna give us business,
but it at least creates a framework of,
like, okay, he knows something.
And so it's a very, very,
listen, there's no business
deal I'll ever make
that is going to feel better than a DM
from somebody who says
that they are happier,
or you've changed their life.
So it's a lot of fun, I
enjoy it tremendously.
And there's another thing that
matters to me quite a bit,
there's not a CEO in the
advertising landscape
who is within a country mile
of actually being a
practitioner in doing creative
and media of me, and I take
a lot of pride in that.
- [Interviewer] Absolutely.
- I'm very thrilled that
I'm in every boardroom
where I'm an actual doer and maker
and distributor of, with
a purpose, which gives
me a disproportionate
competitive advantage in a room.
And I love that.
- So you've got the macro
and the granular at the same time--
- Just don't be in the middle.
- Can I squeeze you for one last question?
- Yes, you can, you can.
(overlapping chattering)
- Great, great.
Okay, last, so here we are in Singapore.
What I'd like to know is, why Singapore,
why not Shanghai, or Hong Kong,
and why aren't you going to China?
I think you read that you were--
- I'm super excited about
going to Mainland China,
I'm just also, have the great fortune
of being born in the former Soviet Union,
and so the cliche, naivety, and audacity
that an American businessman
or woman usually enter China
with is not going to be my narrative.
So I'm going to thoughtfully build a ton
of leverage in the greater
Southeast Asia area,
take advantage that I'll
be here quite a bit,
and continue to pop into Mainland China,
and build my leverage with the KOLs,
I continue to produce
content on Weibo and WeChat.
And when I feel appropriate,
then we'll go and do it,
you know, a merger, or
an M&A, or a partnership,
or whatever finally
then feels appropriate.
So my ambitions for Mainland
China are enormous, and--
- [Interviewer] But you'd go--
- I just want to--
- Acquisition, rather than--
- You have to.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You have to, and then the Hong Kong,
Singapore thing is serendipity,
it could have been either one,
it could have been either one.
(slow electronic music)
Oh, boy.
- How are you doing?
- Fine, it's just up for
fucking 27 hours in a row.
- [DRock] I can't believe
you turned the wifi on.
- I slept seven hours, I
felt great, but I just,
I just thought I was gonna
sleep the last two hours
of the flight, and then two
hours here, and instead, I.
- Gary, what's going on,
how was your meeting?
- Our meeting was super productive,
you were stunned you
got through everything.
I wasn't stunned, because I
don't complicate meetings.
- Yeah, he is, he's easy.
- Right, It was like,
yes, yes, yes, yes.
- Don't overthink shit.
- All right, let's go do
this, so what am I doing?
I'm speaking now?
- [DRock] You're going
to a meeting, right?
- Oh, right, let's do that.
Thank you--
- [Maha] That was great.
(man in green shirt mumbles)
- How are you?
- I hear so much about you.
- Thank you.
- Can I take a picture of you, please?
- Sure.
- Thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
- Okay, wait, sorry, sorry, hold you back.
Here, I'm still, can I pass,
take a picture of me, thank you.
- [DRock] One, two, three, okay.
- [Man In Green Shirt]
Thank you very much.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you.
- [Man In Green Shirt]
Do you do autograph?
- Sure.
- Okay, let me.
- Gary, I miss you in Vegas.
- Yes.
- So I had to fly to
come here to my meeting.
- Is that right, how are you?
- We just came here for a meeting.
- [Gary] How are you?
- We just won a global award together,
our agency--
- Congratulations.
- Can I just take a--
- Yes, sure.
- So we didn't miss out after all.
(overlapping chattering)
You talked on the--
- Amazing.
- By the way, all of our
team is based in Belarus.
- No kidding?
- Yes.
- That's unbelievable, that's awesome.
- [Man In White Shirt]
Good, good to meet you.
- Thank you.
- Nice to meet you.
Take care.
- My name is Edmund.
- Spell it?
- E-D-M-U-N-D.
- E-D?
- M, M-U-N-D, yes.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you, take care.
- Nice to meet you.
- Take care.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
- [Maha] Okay, so.
Let's see.
Okay, there's only four questions.
Okay, I tend of find entrepreneurial life
to be a very lonely place
because of the hours of work
and lack of social life, it
gets to one after a while.
How do you avoid that?
- You're in control of your life, like,
if you are not socializing
enough, socialize.
You know, this whole notion
that there's some sort
of right is crazy, there's
only what's right for you.
And so if you're feeling this month
that you need to socialize
more, socialize more.
If you feel this month
that you need to go harder,
because there's this crazy opportunity,
do that, everybody looking
for this balance is crazy.
'Cause balance is
individual, and so for me,
be accountable, like, you're in control.
Sometimes I go super duper
hard, other, you know,
I've been sleeping a lot more
in the last 18 months than
I have the prior four
years, 'cause I just felt
that was appropriate,
so you're in control.
- [Maha] A lot of battles come your way
when you're trying to succeed,
I see we both tackle them head on, but
sometimes it makes it seem
abrasive to the people around us.
How do you deal with that?
- Well, I'm abrasive on camera,
because I'm not actually
speaking to a human being,
I'm speaking to the masses.
I think something that you
would probably find unusual,
but the people that actually know me,
know to be true is, I'm
actually stunningly not abrasive
in real life, one on one, with anybody.
So I don't have to deal with it.
How do you deal with
it, empathy, understand
that there's truth, and
radical candor can be delivered
with honey, it doesn't have
to be delivered with vinegar.
In real life, I deliver with honey.
In camera life, I deliver sometimes
with a little bit more vinegar.
That's how I do it.
- [Maha] Biggest thing to watch out for
when you're trying to monetize
your social media brand?
- The number one mistake that people make
when they're monetizing
their social media is,
they get too caught up
in the monetization,
and they've lost the
balance of providing value,
and the occasional ask.
To me, it's a seesaw, and
you need to keep it balanced.
And so when you start
monetizing, a lot of times,
people get the high of the monetization,
and become so selfish that
they lose the selflessness
that is required in balance
to be a productive individual
in the current social media landscape.
- [Maha] Last question,
is there still room
for digital growth and new
talent with the rising costs
of ads, both on Facebook and Instagram?
- The rising costs of Facebook
and Instagram is still
so disproportionately under-priced
that there is an
extraordinary amount of room
to still be had in growth, not to mention,
once it's appropriately priced,
no different than, let's
say, Google AdWords,
then you still can win on that platform,
if you're the best.
We're coming out of the era where anybody,
no matter how good or bad they are,
were getting successful on the back
of Facebook and Instagram,
'cause it was egregious how
under-priced the ads are.
Now they're just a screaming
deal, then they'll be a deal,
then they'll be appropriately priced,
and in all those eras,
there's opportunity.
It's just, as it becomes more appropriate,
you just have to be that much better,
because it's one game
of supply and demand.
(slow electronic music)
- I wanted to talk to you about--
- I think it's gonna go to
40 in the next six months.
- Really?
- I think basketball cards
are grossly under-priced,
and once they become global,
'cause basketball's global,
but the demand, I think it's gonna be--
- I saw you posted, you're looking
for pre-1980 basketball cards.
- I am, I think vintage
basketball is the big arbitrage.
And most of my weird stuff,
like, there was Sugar Daddies,
you know, like the,
they had stats of cards
in '73, '75, and '75.
- You want to, I'll give you a little tip.
- Give me a tip.
- Estate sales, you
know, when people have,
like, storage, and they don't know
what's in that storage,
and then they open,
they find treasure troves of stuff--
- You know this is like my main--
- That's, like, your main
thing, you've gotta start--
- You know what I'm really into?
You know what my new thing is, books,
I want to buy old books,
and then carefully go
through every page, remember
when we found the love letter?
- Vintage books?
- [DRock] Oh my God, the letter.
- There's crazy stuff--
- That people put in books?
- Uh-huh.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, so--
- Like cash.
- Olympic training pins,
so I went to the Olympics,
and then we discovered,
like, there's a whole thing
around trading Olympic pins, and then--
- You saw that episode, right?
(overlapping chattering)
Is that true?
- In 1996, I was working
for General Mills--
- Atlanta?
- I got, yeah, I won a Chairman's Award,
you get two tickets to go to the Olympics.
So I took my dad, my dad
didn't attend any of the games,
he was out trading pins the entire time.
- That's amazing.
- And he spent four days of the Olympics,
didn't watch any sporting events,
but you should see our collection.
That's what I'm telling you,
I'm into Olympic training pins.
So I have his coveted
collection, I didn't see that.
No, I saw the pony,
the MyLittlePony thing.
- Oh my god, literally, in New Zealand.
(slow music)
- [DRock] Oh, man, when he
was locking the other pins.
- [Announcer] And the Calgary
Olympics, this large pin,
it can go anywhere from 30 to 50 bucks.
- I can't wait to show you my collection.
- That's the--
- [Gary Voiceover] All
right, guys, we struck again.
This is insane, I just bought a ton
of Olympic pins, he
wanted to a buck apiece,
I got the whole collection.
- Oh, yeah, that comes in the case.
- [Gary Voiceover] One,
two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14--
- It's the best part.
- [Gary Voiceover] 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21,
22, 23, 24, 25, 26, 27, 28, 29, 30, 31,
32, 33, 34, 35, 36, 37,
38, 39, 40, 41 pins.
And the first thing,
he wanted $1.00 apiece,
I paid 20 for the whole thing.
- Are you kidding me?
- I paid 20 for all these, $20.00.
- That's gold.
- Gold.
- What'd you do with it?
- Sold it for 2,000.
- You did?
- Yeah.
(video on phone chatters)
- Well, what you gotta do is
you gotta go to the games.
There's, like, a whole thing
set up at the Olympic Games--
- I know the whole thing.
- [Gary Voiceover] No Starbucks, though,
that's a good opener for the next family.
Give me the, give me the pins.
I just bought--
(overlapping chattering)
- That's insane.
- [Gary Voiceover] Olympic
pins, and I mean, hundreds
for 20 bucks, he wanted $1.00 apiece,
the first sheet had 44,
I paid 20 for it all.
Monday Night Football--
- And then you looked
up and see the value?
- [Gary Voiceover] How many are there, Ty,
can you count them?
(Ty mumbles)
Yeah, just literally, two of the pins.
- [Ty Voiceover] There's a lot of pins.
- I love these episodes.
- [Ty Voiceover] That's about as--
- [Gary Voiceover]
Unpromising as it gets, yeah.
Come on, let's go get the,
it'll be good content.
- [Ty Voiceover] You
want to get out there?
- [Gary Voiceover] Yeah,
come with me. (mumbles)
Jesus Christ.
(Maha and Gary laugh)
- Oh, this was a good one.
- [DRock] Yeah, the Hot
Wheels, the old Hot Wheels.
- Oh, I lost my mind.
- How do you know what's
junk and what's good?
- I've been doing this for 25 years.
- Really?
- Mm-hmm.
(quiet overlapping chattering)
- [Gary Voiceover] Maybe
seven, I'll take these for two.
- And you're negotiating.
- Oh, yeah, I kill people.
- [DRock] Have you not watched them?
- No, I watched them, but
I'm like, sometimes these.
- [Gary Voiceover] She
did it for five bucks,
and it's super vintage matchbox.
- I thought this was worth so much more.
- [Gary Voiceover] But it's worth a lot.
Holy shit, Ty. (background
noise drowns out speaker)
Last box, it's been a car day.
(overlapping chattering)
245 pins.
- 245 pins.
- [Gary Voiceover] Just show you this,
I can just guarantee--
- That was a good one.
- [Gary Voiceover] A matchbox,
B controller X7, I knew it.
Just--
- You're gonna give--
- [Gary Voiceover] Look, just, I mean,
there's a whole slew of
stuff in here, just the,
this one single controller, 60 bucks.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
(group laughs)
30.
- [Ty Voiceover] Wow.
- Wow. (laughs)
(overlapping chattering)
- [Gary Voiceover] 15 to 30, 15 to 30.
Guys, is there any more,
no, there's a whole box--
- Guys, you don't even want to know.
- [Gary Voiceover] I had it for five.
- Got the whole box for five.
- We gotta do you, like,
an international version,
where you go to.
We should create a trading application.
- [DRock] Steve, have we inspired you
to go garage sale-ing?
- [Gary] Oh my god, the
Zelda got a bid, 64 bucks.
- [Maha] Wait, wait, wait, wait.
- [Gary] I bought this for three bucks.
- [Maha] Zelda got a bid for 63.99.
- [DRock] Wow.
- [Maha] Plus $6.00 shipping.
- [DRock] For three bucks,
he bought it for three bucks.
- [Gary] Nerf guns.
- [Maha] How are your
MyLittlePonies, doing,
I mean, Nerf guns--
- 15 bucks.
- [DRock] Wow.
- [Gary] For just--
- [Maha] I bet the guys in
the office are having fun--
- [Gary] $9.00 on one Pony, bid.
- [DRock] Wow.
- [Maha] Wow.
- [Gary] Oh, the mom and
dad mugs got a dollar.
A dollar, milk, milk mugs are on fire.
- [Maha] There was a really
cool mug that you got,
the Strawberry Shortcake,
I used to have that
when I was a kid.
(overlapping chattering)
Where, did that sell?
- [Gary] Well, we've
gotta see if there's bids.
The,
the.
(overlapping chattering)
Yeah, Disney thing, 20.
- [DRock] How much is that worth?
- [Gary] Three.
- [Maha] Ooh, the husky with the--
- [Gary] Oh, yeah.
(overlapping chattering)
Got a bid.
- Got a bid?
- [Gary] Mm-hmm.
- [Maha] I used to have that mug.
- [Gary] Yeah, this mug is classic.
- [Maha] All that retro
stuff makes you feel good.
- [Gary] I agree, oof, three bids on this.
- [Maha] What is it, oh, it's a Nintendo.
(slow electronic music)
- And so let's get the ball rolling.
So, like, why are you doing,
what you are in Singapore for?
- So I have a, I have a speech today,
but in the macro, we're opening our office
for VaynerMedia here
in a couple of months.
And so
I'm gonna be here quite a bit
over the next several years,
working with Avery and
the rest of the team
to establish the office, and so,
yeah, I'm just gonna
be here a whole bunch.
- Cool, I got, probably you
get asked this question a lot,
but I did, like, a, you
know, call to the WeWork team
in France, and to
consolidate your questions.
But one of the questions, you
probably have answered it,
like, have you ever gave any advice
without using profanities?
(Gary laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, you know what's funny is,
really, public events bring
out more of my cursing.
I think I was so affected by Richard Pryor
and Eddie Murphy, and Chris Rock,
I was such a big fan of
standup comedy that it,
subconsciously, I think
blend into my brain.
And so when I started speaking,
which didn't happen until
I was in my mid-30s,
so I never even, like,
saw that as something
I would ever do, I mean,
I was running a wine
E-commerce and retail business.
I remember my mom watched, like,
one of my first speeches, she said, like,
"What the fuck is that?"
(audience laughs)
And I was like, "Yeah, I don't," so.
- Do you stop cursing
when you drink your wine,
or how does it? (laughs)
- No, I get sleepy when
I drink wine, so, no,
I can give plenty of
advice without cursing.
- Okay, that's cool, that's good to know.
So having worked with
so many entrepreneurs,
and maybe seen in your travels that,
are there any, like,
similarities wherever you go,
or differences, especially here in Asia?
- Yeah, I mean, you know, it's funny.
What I really recognize in Asia,
and as everybody here knows,
especially if you're here,
it's just like anything else.
There's so many subcultures,
it's tough to bucket,
especially, you know, if you
think about Southeast Asia,
there's so many different,
using a wine term.
(speaking in foreign language)
There's nuances, but I will say that the
kind of
raw entrepreneurial spirit
in Asia feels exciting
to me, you know, I think,
I think that,
you know, Europe doesn't have it at all.
I think America's version of it right now
is a little interesting,
from the standpoint of,
there's just so many people
that want to be entrepreneurs,
'cause it got cool,
that we're living through
a really interesting time.
But there's,
there's a mix of anxiety and opportunity
in the Asian market that
I think has a little bit
of a raw entrepreneurial
spirit that is very attractive
to me, like, I feel like there's,
there's a lot of opportunity,
and a lot of ambition,
and I think a lot of,
you've got the first generation
that's kind of breaking away
from what their parents want
them to do at scale,
to do entrepreneurship,
which has a really
intriguing dynamic to it.
So the similarity is, at its most pure,
I think entrepreneurs aren't scared,
and that is the one core thing.
And I think the reason I'm aware
that we're living through an over-inflated
entrepreneurial market is I
do think we have executives
and students acting as
entrepreneurs in this era.
And so there's more fear,
and more Excel sheets,
and bullshit in this era, which is fine.
I mean, I don't get to judge, but it
definitely feels like we're in
a bubble of entrepreneurship.
And that usually means it's
gonna burst at some point.
- So what are your
thoughts, like, obviously,
like, in Asia, we don't
really have that much
of these developing kind
of types of VC ecosystem,
and you talk to a lot of entrepreneurs
in (mumbles), right, so any thoughts on--
- I think that's the, I mean,
I'm glad you brought that up,
and that's where I was gonna go next.
I think the great, the great strength
of a lot of the,
the entrepreneurial ventures
that I've come across
in this region is predicated on the fact
that outside of a small group of people,
there isn't as much funding,
and I think funding has
really destroyed the merit
of entrepreneurship in the US
and parts of Asia, for that matter.
And so, you know, it doesn't take a hero
to lose money each month.
And that's what we have right now.
And so I, you're right, I do
encourage people learning how
to make money, I think
it's a much better idea.
You build something much more real,
this notion of, just keep fundraising
until an exit feels like
a game, not a business.
- Cool, maybe
we'll open this time to any
startups on the floor, so yeah.
- [Audience Member] Hi.
- Hello.
- [Audience Member] Gary, my name is,
should I use the mic, or?
- I mean, we can hear.
- [Audience Member] Gary, my name is.
(laughter drowns out speaker)
- He's, like, louder than the--
- [Audience Member] I'm
glad that we assessed
your size right, we bought
you a Perlin T-shirt.
- Thank you so much.
- [Audience Member] Would
like to present this to you.
- Thank you very much, my friend.
(overlapping chattering)
- Hurry up, man, but no, but--
- Thank you.
- So pleased to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- And I'm excited for
you to come to Singapore.
- Thank you.
- So just as a background,
I did 12 years in the environmental space,
so I was one of Time Magazine's
Heroes of the Environment,
I was protecting rainforests,
I raised 400 million dollars
for carbon credits,
got really disappointed
in the governments, and then turned
to unregulated securities, eg, Bitcoin.
So I'm a real big fan of your assessment,
and your cutting the crap on
a lot of cryptocurrencies.
For our, since we ended up
raising 49 million dollars
for our private ground last year,
but what we're doing is really quite,
coming to your point, we've signed deals
with the International
Chamber of Commerce,
45 million different businesses.
And Singapore has turned out
to be this secret repository
of really cool crypto community.
We'd love to be one of your clients,
we'd love to figure out
how to work with you,
because we've been
offered by Binance and 4B,
like, listings in the next couple months.
My question to you was, you know,
Bitcoin has made a recent run, you know,
you've seen this, being
this value of debt,
is it coming back, just overall assessment
on what you're looking to in Singapore,
for example, with the
decentralized community.
But also where you see, you know,
cryptocurrencies going
in the next year or so.
- So I think, appreciate it, thank you.
So I think Blockchain's
been very, you know,
it's funny, and you probably know this,
it sounds like you've
been paying attention.
I haven't really had the
luxury, you know, the internet,
the maturity of the consumer mobile,
you know, social internet
worked out really well for me,
because the timing in my career,
I kind of had my family business in a spot
where it was really operationally running,
and it gave me a little bit of time to,
you know, I was gonna,
and where I deployed
that time was to go very deep
into the mobile social realm.
And that's what materialized
with all the things I did
in being early in Facebook
and Twitter and Tumblr.
I haven't had the same
luxury with Blockchain.
You know, the last, you know, it's funny,
a lot of, you know, probably
two, three years ago,
or a year and a half ago,
at its white heat moment,
a lot of people that
follow me, or interact
with me would razz me, and be like,
why aren't you on top of this?
And I would send them my Coinbase account,
and show them that I bought, you know,
I bought Bitcoin in 2014,
and everyone was like,
what the fuck, you know?
But I didn't have the
luxury of going deep.
But what's very obvious to me,
and I think you've heard this
from me, which is what
you're referencing, is,
I'm very good at pattern recognition.
And the Blockchain technology is very easy
to understand, it's
disproportionally valuable to people.
It's going to cut out a
lot of in between things
that don't bring value,
and skim off the top
for no reason, so the
underlining technology,
I'm outrageously bullish on,
no different than the internet
itself back in the day.
The currencies that layer on top of it,
I view very similar to the search engines
and the browsers of the, you know,
late '90s, early 2000s,
which is the same reason
you were able to raise so much capital,
and that it's a little
harder now to do that,
though there is some resurgence.
Like, ICOs were no different
than the 2001 internet,
you know, blip, there was
completely irrational behavior,
because there's a lot
of money in the system,
and people were literally
walking around, saying,
we're gonna tokenize oxygen,
and people were like,
here's a billion, like, it was very fun
to watch, 'cause I'm like, man, this is
always gonna be the way
everything's gonna be.
New technologies will
emerge, and this will happen.
And I think your ambition, I'm sure,
and anybody else that's in this space,
is to end up being, you
know, a Netscape Navigator,
or a Google, or
whatever the winners are.
And so I think there'll be an
enormous amount of money lost,
and there'll be a couple places
where there's an enormous
amount of money made
on the back of the infrastructure.
But I think much like the way I thought
about the internet in 1996, 1999, 2002,
I don't, I think all of us are now aware,
and have heard this, no
matter how much knowledge
or not knowledge we have around Bitcoin,
or crypto, or Blockchain,
it's in the ethos.
But it's grossly
underestimated by the masses
of what it looks like 15 years from today.
And that's where I spend a lot of my time,
trying to be thoughtful of, like, who's,
what are the shovels and the picks
of that kind of infrastructure,
which inevitably doesn't have the layer
and tollbooths that the internet has,
because of the framework
of the technology.
And so that's kind of how I see it.
- I like how you mentioned
shovels and picks.
Is that one, I mean,
having gone through so many
of these trends, is that something you use
to kind of cut through the noise?
Because with every trend, you know,
people get overwhelmed, right?
Like, with all these jargon in trends,
like, what, how do you look through, like,
you know, business itself, trends,
and then pick the winners?
- Yeah, I think I do, and I
think some of it was intuitive.
You know, I was a super
under-educated kid,
I was a really bad
student, so a lot of stuff,
I've learned almost absolutely everything,
actually, I've learned
everything by doing,
and going through it.
Yeah, I think the gold rush
of the 1800s in the US
continues to play out.
And so I do think about shovels and picks.
I think a lot about
people building companies
on top of other companies,
and then being vulnerable.
I see so much over-valuation,
people building
on top of other things where, you know,
it's very obvious, you know, it's funny
to see Twitter reopen its API, you know?
I saw the headlines, I haven't
read the documentation,
but I'm like, oh, boy, you know,
this was a funny, you
know, play a couple years,
you know, a decade ago, I guess now.
Yeah, I,
now that I'm getting, you know, I'm 43,
so this is, like, maybe
a second or a third
or a fourth turn, you just
see the same things over
and over, for me, the
thing that I always do,
and that has been tried and true,
and that, if I could leave
anything for anybody in here
that I do think would be valuable,
I reverse engineer the audience.
Like, to me, what works for my content,
what worked for me in the wine store,
what works for us at VaynerMedia,
work works always is, do you understand
who you're servicing, the end consumer?
And does every decision, thought process,
and maneuver benefit that person?
The cynicism and the scrutiny undertone
that I started with is, I believe 99%
of startups pander to venture capitalists,
not the customer of their product.
So inevitably, they're
already in trouble, and so
one thing that would
bode well for all of you,
in life, as a human, and definitely
in your businesses, is
who are you servicing,
and are you just religious about that?
Oftentimes, people are
fascinated by how little
I know about the industry I'm in.
It's because I spend no
time on my competition
or anything else, 'cause
it's just 100% predicated
on the current state of the
end consumer of that product.
And I think that will really matter.
- Yes.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
So good to finally meet
you, I've been following
you for four years, I'm
sort of nervous right now.
- Don't worry, thank you.
- [Audience Member] I'm
sure you get that a lot.
- I'm flattered.
- [Audience Member] I never
thought that would happen,
but yeah.
- Thank you.
- [Audience Member] So,
I mean, like, I know
you get this a lot, but you
fundamentally changed my life,
man, 2017, quit my data
management consulting job.
I come from India, I've lived in Singapore
for about nine years,
got my cost of living,
that was your call.
Started a podcast for decrypt
Asia, it's a crypto podcast,
the only one covering
crypto news from Asia.
Started writing for tech in Asia,
which is the equivalent of tech (mumbles).
Started getting hit by
family offices, VCs,
to figure out what I was up to, managed,
so one of the VCs that hit me up,
you know, it was a casual meeting from,
from one of the articles
that I wrote on tech in Asia.
They liked my views, so it
was a combination, I think
you're on one extreme, and
then Naval Ravikant is kind
of on the other extreme, and I
think my sort of philosophies
of, like, fall somewhere in the middle
of what you talk about,
and what Naval talks about.
So he basically talks
about leveraging capital,
media, and tech, and so the
podcast was leverage media.
Managed to be the first
employee at a VC fund,
crypto VC fund, built it up from scratch.
So it's been about a year at this VC fund,
but it's been an absolute, I mean,
it's been the craziest
year of my life, man,
so thanks a lot.
- It makes me happy.
- [Audience Member] There's no question.
(audience laughs)
- Thank you. (laughs)
(audience applauds)
(overlapping chattering)
- Awesome.
I'm sure you get that
quite a lot on the street.
- Yeah, I mean, look, I
think, I think, you know,
it's a really fun segue from
what I just said earlier.
Like, one of the reasons I have the life
that I have is, every single
piece of content I put out
in the internet, I
desperately, desperately,
desperately am thinking subconsciously
and consciously of, how
will this help somebody
that consumes it, not, how
is this going to get likes
or followers, so then I
can do a branded post,
and make, like, when
you're, when you are 100%,
not 99, and definitely not 30,
when you are 100%
consumer-centric, audience-centric,
incredibly good things happen.
And I just, I'm fascinated
by people's inability
to understand that providing
more value than you ask
for in return is always
a tremendous model,
and yet, people are so incapable
of playing the long game.
People are so disproportionately insecure
to prove they're successful to everybody,
that they're pandering to such short-term.
And so I believe the world
is filled with nothing
but sprinters, and I'm a marathon runner,
and life is actually a marathon.
And so you can imagine the
confidence I roll through
in the framework that I've created,
and that comes from the
humility of being an immigrant,
that comes from incredible fortune
of having a mother who
disproportionately built self-esteem
in me, which allows me not to pander
to outside voices that lack
the context of who I am.
And it's been very, it's
been very rewarding,
and then what ends up happening is,
when you start getting a little older,
and you start becoming so grateful
for the framework, 'cause you
realize you're the byproduct
of circumstance and great parenting,
it makes you then want to do things,
like you're almost, I feel
like I'm almost guilted,
and, you know, I always think
about guilt and gratitude.
You know, I just,
I feel like, you know those
flies go into the light
and get buzzed and die, like,
they know what's happening,
but they can't stop,
it's kind of how I feel
about making content.
You know, I'll be very frank with you,
it was interesting to hear what you,
your observation of
somebody who's consumed me.
I think I am remarkably
underrated for my operational
and business capabilities because
of my over-exaggerated
personality in producing content,
I'm being serious.
You know, I've taken
VaynerMedia, as the CEO
and COO, for that matter, I
have operated it every day,
I've taken it from zero
to 200 million dollars
in revenue with no cash infusion,
started it in a conference room,
it's now my second
company that I've built,
early investor in
Facebook, Twitter, Tumblr,
like, all that stuff, yet
it's, you know, I think,
it's really fascinating
for me that the thing
that I feel that I'm giving
the most with is the thing
that also, in return,
creates
a narrative that
actually, it doesn't bother me,
but as you can imagine,
when you love what you do,
and you think you're good at it,
there's a fascinating relationship I have
with my content, because
I absolutely am very aware
that it undermines my
capabilities as an operator
and an executive, which is fine,
because that's so much
more fun to hear than,
you know, than anything
else, but it is fascinating.
- So you mentioned that
this is a marathon,
and you had Wine Library,
and now VaynerMedia,
at what, how,
how many areas get you, like, in between?
I mean, obviously people say, oh,
we're successful and what you
do is you just make content,
right, but I'm pretty sure
that a lot of happened,
else, in between, so.
- You know, I haven't had a macro failure,
because I'm too much of an immigrant,
and I don't over-leverage myself, right?
So I haven't had a macro failure.
I have micro failures on a daily basis.
You know, I lose money all
the time on initiatives
and executions and divisions and concepts,
but I've never put myself out of business.
And for me, it's just binary,
either you're making payroll,
or you're not, and, you know,
I've made payroll every single week
since I was 22 years
old, and I proud of that,
'cause it's practical as fuck.
So, but yeah, I mean, you know,
any time you're running businesses,
you're making super duper
mistakes on an every day basis.
And I think a lot of the mistakes
I make are actually the things I don't do,
versus the things that I do.
When you're, when you get into a place
where you're crippled by opportunity,
you're just passing on
things left and right.
And so, but, you know, the other thing,
you know, it's funny where my
mind goes on this question,
you know, I also don't
have a year to really dwell
on losses, you know,
I always struggled to,
like, come up with them,
because I feel like I give them
so little value.
Like, I'm just, you know, one
thing I wish more people did
and had is the year to not dwell.
Like, to me, I'm just
thrilled for the at bat,
so it makes me hard to be upset about,
you know, people just beat themselves up.
And, like, I don't know, you know?
- I do that every day.
- Do you?
- Like, sometimes.
- Yeah, I'm the other way,
I'm not delusional, right?
It's not like, but I'm just,
I just feel like it's
the cost of the game.
Like, it's, you know, if
you're truly the leader
of something, or if you're
truly, like, own something,
or the last line of defense, by nature,
everything is a problem, like,
my entire day is 98% headaches.
Like, I think an entrepreneur
is the closest thing
to a firefighter, right, like, you're
just on-call at all times for some shit.
There is no relaxation, like, you know,
you're just always on,
I don't like even being
on a plane for 17 hours without wifi,
because something's
inevitably gonna be a problem
when you have 1,000 employees,
global this and that, so.
I don't even think there's time to dwell.
- [Brian] Hello, Gary, my name is Brian.
So I'm just really passionate
about digital marketing.
The truth is people keep beating you up--
- That's a great question.
- [Brian] How did you do it?
- The first 10 or 20
people were either friends
of my brother and I, or
disproportionately delusional fans of me.
(audience laughs)
Because,
because I wanted a very
insular family dynamic
that was completely predicated on trust,
so that we could go fast.
I think speed is a stunningly
underrated, people talk
about it, but I think people
prefer process over speed,
it makes people comfortable.
And I think speed is
unbelievably important,
and the only way you get fast
with people is when there's trust.
The reason companies suck
is it's all politics,
and everybody gets slow,
everybody's worried
about shit that they
shouldn't be worried about,
thus not the task at hand.
So I would highly recommend,
if you're capable, I had the advantage
of being in my second
chapter of my career,
and I also had the great luxury
that my brother was a much
better student than I was,
and hung out with much more
capable people than I did,
and so that first group was easier.
But I really believe the way I,
listen, everybody needs to
run a company their way,
because there's no right way,
there's only right for you.
For me, every, the two
companies that I've really run,
and, like, the things that I've impacted,
we just had a very major exit
from an incubated company
from my fund, Resy, which
just sold to American Express.
And that one, as well,
like, it's the same model,
which is, I treat businesses like I think
about parenting children,
I believe the first three
to five years is
disproportionate, obnoxious love,
honey, warmth, like, nobody's scared,
like, I take on all responsibility.
And then I think about kind of, like,
year seven through 12 as, like, okay,
now we start eliminating entitlement.
And I'll tell you, I think I
missed the mark at VaynerMedia,
I think I started creating a lack
of entitlement 18 to 12 months too late,
which created a little
bit of a vulnerability
for us for a period, and it was painful.
You know, once, you know, a spoiled,
rich kid getting off a drug is
tough, so we had a little bit
of a tough year, because there
was too much entitlement.
But I think anything you
can do to create safety
and speed, I think those
two assets really matter
in the first five years of a company.
- [Brian] Okay, (mumbles), thank you.
- You're welcome.
- We got time for one more, I think.
- [Audience Member] I recently
was watching an interview,
which you declared that
you missed out on Uber.
- Yes.
(audience member mumbles)
- [Audience Member] Even
if Travis Kalanick pitch
to you a couple of times--
- Two times.
- [Audience Member] I think,
I think you read, the book,
you wrote somewhere--
- The first book I wrote, the
only person I thanked was him,
besides my family.
- [Audience Member] Do you have any advice
on the most common errors you should avoid
when you (mumbles) investing (mumbles)?
- I think, you know,
you know what's funny, the
mistake I made there was
I was too logical, right,
like, it was a side project,
and I don't think side
projects tend to turn,
especially 'cause I knew
Garrett and Travis super well,
and they were angel investing,
and doing other stuff,
and I'm like, they're distracted.
So,
you know, God, the, it is
such an imperfect science,
investing, you know,
here are a couple things that have really,
here's where I'm going with the
rest of my investing career.
I'm only gonna invest on two core things
that happen with me through
my pattern of recognition.
One, I intuitively believe in it, blindly,
no logic against it, I have the feeling,
I have the goosebumps, the
hair on the back of my head,
I feel it, it feels it, I'm going, two,
I'm now, at this point in my career,
a believer that it's 80% the founder,
20% the idea, not 50, 50, and so to me,
the things that are obvious to me now are,
bet on the jockey, not the
horse, and if you really feel it,
go with it.
But missing out on that Uber bet,
that was so much circumstance,
bro, it was a side project,
I had just done two side
projects that did not work out,
so I was imposing my belief on that.
I just bought a really expensive apartment
for me in Manhattan,
so I was not as liquid
as I was accustomed to.
I'm an immigrant, so sure
enough, I go a little on defense,
it cost me a half a
billion dollars, you know?
You know, the other
mistake I've made a lot,
and I've stopped making,
back to the jockey versus the horse.
Where I really made my mistakes,
where I really lost the most
amount of money in 2013,
'14 was, I loved the idea, I knew that I,
what I would do with
it, and I misunderstood
that the founder wasn't capable
of operating it the way I would.
So I put myself in the position of CEO,
I knew what to do with it,
but she or he wasn't capable
of doing that, and that's why it failed.
- Okay, one last one, sir.
- [Audience Member] Gary, thank you for--
- Thanks for the shoes,
bro, appreciate it.
- [Audience Member] Is that--
- These are gonna be the next ones, yeah.
- [Audience Member] All right,
I'll have my eyes on it.
- Thank you.
- [Audience Member] I told
myself I wasn't gonna be nervous,
but I'm feeling it right now.
(audience laughs)
Yeah, 'cause (mumbles).
- Thank you.
- [Audience Member] But I
think I should be honest,
prior to that, I didn't like you.
- I understand, it's a very common pattern
of my career.
(audience laughs)
- [Audience Member] Yeah, so really,
thank you for what you
do, because I'm actually
in the insurance business, financial.
So I do consulting on my (mumbles) client,
and things like that,
kind of lost a little bit
of my passion in 2017, 2018.
Well, not really passion, but
because of what I've learned
from you, because I feel
those are very real things,
I feel like all businesses
need to actually go
through probably a different
(mumbles) in terms of, like,
how we educate, you
know, on the mass market
of the insurance, because so far,
it's always been push, push, push.
And ever since I came into the business,
six to eight years ago, I see
very little improvement in that (mumbles).
- It's a sales organization.
- [Audience Member] Yeah, so,
I started to actually
take some of your advice,
as to (mumbles) really
try to put out content,
but I feel there's so
much I want to learn.
And because the nature of my
work is actively controlling
my time, I just want to
actually give it one shot,
because I, you know,
regret asking you this.
Can I, is there any way, I
come, you know, I signed up
for your, like, VaynerMedia
to be opened in Singapore.
Is there any way I can
actually do a part-time job,
anything, you can pay
me (mumbles) anything
outside of my normal working hours?
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
Just send me an email.
And we'll try to figure something out.
(audience member mumbles)
Just Gary at VaynerMedia.
- [Audience Member] Okay.
- Yeah, just say you're
the guy with the shoes,
and you hated me at first,
(audience laughs)
and, you know, just context.
- [Audience Member] Cool,
yeah, thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- How are you doing on
time, do you have time?
- [Maha] We have a couple more minutes,
I just want to give people
a chance to take pictures.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Maha] That's it.
- Okay, why don't I go first, shall I?
(overlapping chattering)
(audience laughs)
- Let's sneak in one
more, one more question.
(overlapping chattering)
Anybody else?
- [Maha] Anyone else have a question--
- Yes, sir?
- Malcolm.
- [Malcolm] I'm Malcolm,
I work for WeWork.
You mentioned three times just now,
and you, absolutely screamed at me,
Richard Pryor, Chris Rock,
and Eddie Murphy, right?
I'm really curious, and I
want to understand how you,
what you took away from
these hall of fame comedians,
in terms of their (mumbles)
perspectives, how you--
- You know, it's funny,
I didn't even realize,
you know, like, I didn't realize
I was taking anything away
from them, I thought I was driving to work
and laughing while I was driving to work.
What I've recognized and
why I referenced them is,
my cadence and the way I
deliver my speeches looks more
like a comedian than it
looks like a keynote speaker.
So this is what's so amazing, you know,
these two young gentlemen
are mentioning it,
what's amazing when
you're a communicator is,
you don't even realize how
you're impacting people, right?
Like, even when, even when
you don't even realize
you're being impacted, like,
when I make video content,
it also, like, when I speak,
it's definitely those guys.
When I make video content,
I actually think it's more like
Randy the Macho Man Savage.
Like, I think a lot of my cadence
in making videos is more
like doing a wrestling promo,
you know, like, and so
I picked up mannerisms and cadence
in communicating from them,
which, you know, what
I love about comedy is,
they're taking you into a journey,
and you're not exactly sure what,
and then boom, it's a thing.
And I think that's worked
really well for me onstage,
which is, I'm setting up a narrative,
and then boom, I go this way or that,
which makes it entertaining enough.
I'm very happy that I have a, look,
I'm not happy that I have
a communication style
that many people
initially misinterpret me,
and I understand that.
And I'm empathetic to it, like,
who's got time to analyze everybody?
So they see some brash
video, and they're like,
fuck this guy, I get it,
but at the same token,
I'm thrilled to have that style,
because the amount of
people that are entertained,
and then subtly realize, wait a minute,
I'm learning something,
or it's helping them,
or you're saying something
they've heard a thousand times,
you're just saying it
from such a unique angle,
or some sort of style, that you
actually penetrate somebody.
Because you know what's
crazy, I'll say this,
what completely blows my
mind is how much life is
actually singularly based on perspective.
Like, you find what you're looking for.
Like, if you want to find
negativity, it's unlimited.
If you want to find
positivity, it's unlimited,
and the reality, and we
reference it a little bit before,
and it's very prominent in Asia,
so many people are
dictated by the perspective
of their parents, which is
a very dangerous framework,
because parents are coming from yesterday,
and we're gonna live in tomorrow.
And this is the death of businesses,
and this is the death of
current parenting in the world.
And so
I'm excited that I have a
unique, for whatever reason,
communication style that helps
sometimes people see things
from a different angle.
- [Malcolm] Cool, thank you.
- Thank you.
- [Man In Green Plaid] Quick question,
is there anyone you
follow on social media?
- I don't, I spend all
my time reading comments
from my community, and
reading the commentary
of trending conversations in culture.
Like, a lot of times,
I'm not even sure what's,
the Twitter API thing, I
actually don't know the details,
I know the response of 4,000
people's point of view on it.
And so I'm so deeply consumer-centric that
I don't need somebody
else's interpretation
of the consumer, I want my own take on it,
and I'm willing to do
the work to consume that.
I don't want somebody recapping it for me,
because I think, in the
same way I think about,
I laughed when big data
became the thing, right?
Became a thing in our, I'm
like, big data's great,
analyzing the data and doing something
with it is the punchline,
and so a lot of times
we put the thing on the pedestal,
not what we're doing with that thing.
And so for me, I'm, I'm very passionate
about consuming people's
reactions to culture and things,
and then synthesizing
it, and making decisions,
which I think has historically
has allowed me to be,
there's a reason I've been
so early on all these things,
and a lot of it has to do
with that kind of system.
- All right, all right, thank you, Gary.
- Thank you.
- Can I get a shot of us with the group?
- Sure.
- Would it be all right?
Wouldn't it be cool?
- I'll get you. (mumbles)
(quiet overlapping chattering)
- All right, get in, get in, everyone.
(overlapping chattering)
One, two, three, and one more.
- Awesome.
- Okay, thank you so much.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you, thank you, guys.
(audience applauds)
Thank you, thank you.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
- Can I get an interview with you?
It's not for mass media,
it's for something else.
Whom shall I talk about?
- Where's, Maha?
(overlapping chattering)
- [Woman In Pink] Thank you, thanks a lot.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Can I get a shot with you, Gary?
It's so nice to see you in person.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- I'm Sarah, I work at WeWork.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- Thank you so much, it was inspirational.
- [Gary] Thank you so much, thank you.
- I'm wondering, are
you Ukrainian by origin?
- Belarusian.
- Belarusian?
(speaking in foreign language)
(overlapping chattering)
Me and Julia are Ukrainian.
- That's awesome.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Can we take a picture with you?
(overlapping chattering)
- Awesome.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Thank you so much.
- Yeah, of course.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you.
- Can I take a picture with you?
(overlapping chattering)
- Awesome.
- [Man In Green Plaid]
Can we do your signature?
- [Gary] Yeah, of course.
- [Man In Green Plaid] Awesome.
- [Gary] Awesome, brother, thank you.
- [Man In Blue Polo] Very
nice to meet you, man.
- Really nice to meet you, man.
Congratulations.
(overlapping chattering)
Awesome.
Thank you, brother, hi, hi.
(overlapping chattering)
- Nice to meet you, nice
to meet you, I'm Bella.
(overlapping chattering)
- Awesome, nice to meet you, thank you.
- As well, sorry.
- No worries.
- [Photographer] You're popular.
- [Woman In Pink] We're, like, yeah,
in national dress today.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you.
- Thank you, thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Man With Fade Haircut]
Hey, thank you so much.
- You got it brother, thank you.
- Hi, thank you so much.
- I'll talk to you, your--
- Yeah, Avery, you know what,
you should talk to Avery,
I saw her perk up when you
said maybe work together.
- Yeah.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Photographer] One, two, three, got it.
- You got it, DRock?
(overlapping chattering)
Avery!
- Which one's Avery?
- Avery.
In the yellow dress back there.
- [Man With Fade Haircut]
All right, let me give
you my card, anyway.
- Please.
- [Made With Fade Haircut] I'll find,
but done 20 startups, failed
six to eight times, move on.
- That's awesome, brother.
- And we're gonna do this one.
- [Gary] Pleasure.
- [Man With Fade Haircut]
I'll go. (mumbles)
- Please, hi.
- Nice meeting you.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Lilly] Lilly.
- [Gary] So nice to meet you.
(overlapping chattering)
- [DRock] One, two, okay, got it.
- Thank you.
- Such a pleasure.
- [Lilly] Such a pleasure, thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Man With Fade Haircut]
So, yeah, hi, Avery.
- Thank you for your question, thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you.
You got it.
(overlapping chattering)
- [DRock] Three, two, one.
- Thanks.
- You got it, thank you.
- Thank you so much, Gary--
- Thank you, man.
- I'll email you.
- Such a pleasure.
(overlapping chattering)
Awesome.
- I wish you all the best in Singapore.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Man In Yellow Shirt]
All right, how are you?
- Pleasure, how are you?
(overlapping chattering)
- [Man In Pink Shirt]
Can we take a selfie?
- Yeah, let's do it.
(overlapping chattering)
You got it, cheers.
How are you?
- How are you?
- Nice to meet you.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you.
- [Man In Gray Shirt] By
the way, Dan Chavel is one
of my best friends.
- Is that right?
- [Man In Gray Shirt] He
says hello, he's a good dude.
- He is a good dude.
- Let's do it.
(overlapping chattering)
- Awesome.
- So a great job.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- I actually just moved here from LA.
- That's awesome.
- So I saw Avery, talked--
- Congrats, thank you.
- Yeah, thank you.
- Pleasure.
- Good to see you.
- [Man In Camo Jacket] Hello
again, Gary, nice to meet you--
- Nice to meet you.
(overlapping chattering)
Awesome, thank you.
Hi, how are you, nice to meet you.
Hi, nice to meet you.
(overlapping chattering)
- Thank you.
Thanks.
- Thank you so much
for being here, thank you.
- Hi, Gary, it's me again.
- How are you, good to
see you guys, how are you?
(overlapping chattering)
Such a pleasure.
- Thank you.
- Thank you, guys, take care.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Man In Ball Cap] I
was hoping to see Gabby.
- Gabby, (laughs) Gabby's sleeping.
(overlapping chattering)
- Hi, how are you?
- Hi, nice to meet you.
(overlapping chattering)
- [DRock] One, two, three, got it, got it.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- [Woman In Yellow Jacket] Thank you.
- Thank you, pleasure.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you, hi.
How are you?
(overlapping chattering)
So nice to meet you, hi, nice to meet you.
Phone, oh, you forgot it?
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you.
- Okay, thank you.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Man In T-Shirt] Hey, Gary.
- How are you?
- Welcome to Singapore, thank you.
- Nice to meet you.
(overlapping chattering)
Hi, how are you?
- Nice to meet you.
(overlapping chattering)
- Oh, thanks a lot, man.
- Nice to meet you.
Thank you for being here,
thanks for being here.
(overlapping chattering)
Ready?
Hi, how are you?
(overlapping chattering)
Hi, good to see you, nice to meet you.
Who's taking a photo?
(overlapping chattering)
Oh.
- [Photographer] Three, two,
one, shot, just a moment.
Just a moment, three, two, one, thank you.
- Thank you.
- Awesome.
Thank you, guys, thank you for coming.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Man In White Collared
Shirt] Congratulations.
- Thank you.
- I follow you
since the Wine Library,
and I show your video
to French Quarter, because I work in Italy
with the French Quarter--
- Thank you.
Beautiful sparkling wine, how are you?
- When you were speaking
the New York Jets.
- Yes, (laughs) thank you.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Photographer] One, two, three.
- Awesome.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you so much,
thank you for having me,
thank you for your question.
(overlapping chattering)
All right.
- Is there anything I can help you with
in Singapore, anything you're looking for?
- [Gary] Reach out to me, and we'll,
we'll figure it out, we're
just, we're slow and steady,
but there may be.
- Whatever you want, right?
- [Gary] Thank you, thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Fan] Thanks for coming down, Gary.
- [Gary] Thanks for having
me, thank you, we're good?
- [Fan] Thanks, Gary, I
hear you're doing some work
with John Max Bolling?
- Yes.
- [Fan] I just wanted
to come and say hello.
- [Gary] Thank you, how are you?
- [Fan] Good, thanks.
- [Gary] Good, thanks for having me, yeah.
Thank you, thanks for being
here, have a great day.
Ready, let's go.
(overlapping chattering)
- Hey, I'm Jesse.
- Thank you.
Jesse.
- Thanks for coming.
- Thank you so much.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Bye, guys, Risa, you're staying?
- [Avery] Yeah, she's staying--
- Okay, thank you, Jesse.
(overlapping chattering)
Hi.
- [Maha] Not bad.
- [Gary] It worked out.
- [Maha] We wanted to leave at 4:40.
- [Gary] We nailed it.
- [Maha] Okay, Gary, is
it recording on your side?
Are you ready to go, is it live?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- We're always on.
- [Maha] I'm very excited
to have you on my podcast.
- [Gary] Thank you very much, Maha.
- So I have a couple of
questions from some listeners,
so I'm gonna start with those first,
'cause I like to take
care of the people first.
One of your fans in the
Middle East is asking,
what's the best way to grow a community
of people on social media from nothing?
- By not worrying about the growth.
I think almost everybody,
when they start at zero,
are so insecure that all
these people have tens
of thousands, and millions, and a lot
of people right now feel
like they're catching up,
whether that's an A-list
celebrity, which is why a lot
of A-list celebrities from
traditional media are struggling
on social, they don't like the perception
that they're not big, so
they're staying off completely,
or if it's just an average Joe or Jane
that are trying to get onboard.
So, a, don't pander to the numbers, b,
bring value, and whatever
value you have to the audience.
Don't fake it till you'll make it,
because there's too much content,
it doesn't work the way it used to.
And, you know, I think of it as, like,
you know, I think of it as, listen,
five years ago, I had
zero muscles in my body.
I had never worked out in
my entire life with weights,
I had none, and so that first
year was, like, painful,
like, eight pushups, real pushups,
not like the fake ones, were hard.
But understanding that I was gonna do this
for the rest of my life
was what really allowed it
to be palpable in those first two years,
when it seemed daunting.
And somebody starting a social
media account right now,
knowing that this is something
they want to use for the rest
of their lives, all of
a sudden, how you do
in the first six months doesn't
feel like a failure anymore
when you know you're doing it forever.
So having the right
perspective and framework
I think matters, and then recognizing why
somebody would listen to
you or follow you is if
you're uniquely yourself,
then you're different
than everybody else, and
leaning into your perspectives,
the things that you
actually know, being humble
where you need to be
humble, being confident
confident is very important.
- [Maha] Yeah, yesterday
you tweeted, "Patience,"
and I retweeted it, and I
have learned a lot from you.
But if somebody says to me,
what's the number one thing
you learned from Gary Vee,
I will say it's patience.
It's having the longterm
view of the marathon,
not the sprint, and to not be worried
about rushing to get stuff done,
because it'll come if you
just focus on the stuff
in front of you, talk to
me a little bit about--
- And real quick.
- Patience.
- And real quick, yeah, I'm
sorry, thank you for the segue.
I wanted to add this, because
this is our lives together,
kind of, like, what you know about me,
now as you've gotten
closer, I'm macro patient.
But I'm quite frantic
on an every day basis,
I'm constantly busy, like, everyone,
when people hear that
from me, they're like,
what are you talking about?
I'm, like, you mistake me being productive
on a daily basis in, and you're
misusing the word patience.
I'm patient in the macro,
I'm productive in the daily.
- [Maha] In the micro,
that's really interesting.
So the--
- Like that one, right?
- [Maha] The second question
I have for my listeners,
what is the biggest
opportunity a 20-year-old,
a 22-year-old content creator
living in Dubai is seeking
to empower others.
- There's,
so, you know, the advantage of that is,
if you're actually
seeking to empower others,
you need to be self-aware
that you're 22 years old,
and that a lot of people are
not gonna take you serious
in your self-empowerment,
so your advantage is
that you live in a very unique place
that's extremely beautiful,
has a lot of access,
and has a lot of unique dynamics,
that I would lean into that,
and this is a great place
to talk about fake it till you make it.
It's very not interesting for most people
to have a 22-year-old life coach.
- [Maha] Yeah, of course.
- So you could empower people
through your anxieties,
hurdles, strengths, excitements.
I will continue to push
people to their truth.
My mom, at 22 years old, lost her mother,
had her dad go to jail for 10 years,
got married, had a child, and moved
from Russia to America
and started with nothing.
That's a lot to happen at 22,
a lot of people at 22
haven't done anything yet.
You know, so.
If, what are, you know,
what you need to do is tell
your true story, and
the uniqueness of being
in Dubai is one of those pillars.
- [Maha] Okay, I will
give him that key fact.
What are you obsessed with?
- A lot of things, actually,
I can get quite passionate,
garage sale-ing, no, what am I--
- [Maha] Garage sale-ing. (laughs)
- I'm obsessed with seeing it through.
- [Maha] Okay.
I'm unbelievably aware
that I'm not average,
that it's not normal, that
it's not, like, the masses,
and that I've been gifted
through circumstance,
DNA, parenting, and a
million other things,
something that's a little more unusual,
and I'm obsessed with seeing it through.
- [Maha] Okay, I love
that, I love that answer.
So you talked about this--
- It's a cool answer.
- [Maha] A little bit at the--
- [DRock] I want you to expand upon it,
'cause I really don't understand
about seeing it through.
- I'm hyper-aware that I'm
gifted with certain things
that are making me live a
remarkable life, and I'm excited
to respect that gift, and put
in the work and the patience,
and giving back, and doing as
many right things as possible
to allow me to do this
for as long as possible,
so I can put a body of work down
that will leave a tremendous
legacy, and one that can impact
and create value for people in perpetuity.
Not to go where I like
to go in my own mind.
If I'm as special as I
like to think I might be,
well, I'm going to be one
of the first generation
of special people who's
gonna put a lifetime
of content documented throughout.
Do you know how crazy it
would be daily vlogging
and content creation
was around when people
that we admire over
the last 200 years had?
Do you know how much fun
it would be, and I'm not,
just to hedge it so people
don't think I'm crazy,
but it would be really rad
to watch the daily vlog
of Abraham Lincoln.
I would watch that today,
I would today watch Abraham
Lincoln at 19 pontificating
about his, and being
wrong and being right.
Something I would watch
is 19-year-old Bill Gates,
and his thoughts, and how,
'cause I like pattern recognition,
right, it's the great thing
that Muhammad Ali did.
Muhammad Ali understood what I understand,
which is why he was always in the media.
Muhammad Ali used Howard Cosell
as much as Howard Cosell
used Muhammad Ali,
and that's why we have great documentaries
about Muhammad Ali, 'cause
he was a media hound.
And so, I'll say it one more time, not,
you know, I recognize
I've used some big names,
so I'm gonna say it one
more time, I do not, listen,
fuck it, my ambition is to
be bigger than those fuckers,
like, why not have that ambition?
Whether that's true or not,
I have no idea, but I'm,
I'm passionate to see it through.
And when you're a
marathon runner, like me,
the last chapter is the great unveil.
- [Maha] So the best is yet to come.
- 100%, I'm not, I'm putting
down foundational pieces,
I haven't unveiled yet.
- I even think it's interesting,
when I talk to you about
some stuff related to work,
and you're like, "Maha, we've got time.
"We've got time, we're 10 years from now,
"20 years from now, we've got time."
So one of the things,
I've worked with a lot
of different companies and
CEOs throughout my career,
but what makes you
different in my view, and I,
well, the one thing I want
a lot of people to know more
about in Gary Vee, 'cause you
touched upon it in WeWork,
that people see you when
your video is talking,
and it's not really maybe
who you are face-to-face, or.
You spend a lot of time, Gary,
talking about entitlement,
kindness, empathy, and self-awareness.
Not a lot of CEOs are talking
about a lot of those topics,
right, and you're all about
that, which is what I'm very,
well, that's why I was so drawn to you,
because you talk about being a human,
bringing your whole self to work.
Why are those things so important to you,
and why is no one else talking about it?
- They're important to me
because they're the things
that I think that matter.
They're the things that I think have led
to my happiness, they're the things
that I see in others,
bring them happiness.
I think that most people
don't talk about it because,
a million different things,
I don't think it was
in the consciousness, I
think most people don't lead.
I think most people follow, so
if there's nothing to follow,
then people don't talk.
I think that
most people aren't as
emotionally self-aware,
or actually, I think most, listen,
most people are not contradictions.
Most alpha winning business
people are not as soft skilled
as I am.
- [Maha] It's still important
that they have that.
Like, you talked about perspective,
if you either want to,
you see, talk about that.
You, in the--
- You like that one?
- [Maha] Yeah.
- I think it's true,
actually, and honestly,
it's a little bit blown my mind, like,
it's weird to me that life is
actually just one simple game
of, how do you see it, it
actually is weird to me.
Like, I bring up this analogy a lot,
that picture, where it's, like,
either two people kissing,
or it's a champagne glass.
That's life, like, everybody's living,
and people have very different
point of views on things.
And your parents have
historically been a huge factor.
Media has historically been a huge factor,
traditional media, and
I think the internet is
creating a whole new dynamic, and I think
we're focusing again on
a lot of the negative.
We're going through that right now,
what the internet does in
allowing different voices
to, like, spread different opinions,
which can be quite
radical in a lot of ways.
But yeah, I mean, I'm
optimistic, I'm positive,
I have good perspective,
I try to remind people
that, you know, we once
had the black plague,
we once had the Holocaust,
we once had a lot of things
that are much scarier than
the things we're living
through now, and so if you
choose to see the world today
and say, at least we don't
have slavery at scale,
at least we don't have the black plague.
At least we don't have a World War
that's killing tens of
millions of people, huh,
maybe this is better.
Percent of people on
social media are like,
"This is the worst era
ever," and I'm just,
like, laughing at it, so yeah.
I mean, I'm an optimist, I'm positive,
but I'm not delusional,
and so I appreciate you,
you know, when you say I
talk a lot about entitlement,
that makes me happy, because that's,
that's the hedge against, when people hear
me spewing gratitude, or kindness,
or things of that nature.
It's really funny, when
I read my comments,
if we're talking just about
left or right, or just, like,
soft or hard, it's almost
like I don't have a home.
Like, people that want to
see negative are razzing me
for the opposite thing,
like, people are like,
he's too soft, he's too hard, like,
it's really funny to watch.
The reality is, I have a lot of views
that scale in a lot of
different directions, but I,
I like sharing, I like sharing my truths,
I like it a lot, and I also think,
I also think that it creates context
that allows people to do something with.
And I'm, I like that empowerment,
I love that feeling that, right now,
I'm saying something that
actually may benefit somebody.
And I like that legacy.
- [Maha] So what's the
deal with the sports cards
and the garage sales?
- Well, the garage, they're
a little bit different.
Garage sales has just been a real hobby,
I just genuinely enjoy it.
Like, I'm literally, this is
literally what I'm thinking.
I'm thinking, I thought this
three times today, damn,
since I'm flying back and I land too late
on Saturday morning, I
can't go garage sale-ing,
plus I have to go to
Qatar the next morning.
Like, that's, like, inappropriate for me
to come and miss half
the day with my family.
But, like, probably I want to, like,
probably, deep down, like, the, like,
it's funny, I think we're
passing the golf course,
or I don't know, it's really funny,
I think about golf a lot.
So many of my contemporaries,
on a Saturday morning,
will wake up at 6:30 and
go play six hours of golf.
And that is, like, a
real passion of theirs,
and they enjoy it, and everybody
thinks it's a great hobby,
and this and that.
I'd much rather go garage sale-ing
for those same four or five hours,
but it's exactly the same thing.
Hiking, you know, going to
a concert, it's escapism.
Garage sales, the thrill of
the hunt takes over every one
of my problems, and so I love that.
Sports cards' different,
sports cards was the biggest passion
of my life from 1986 to 1993.
And that completely eliminated, walked,
outside of 2003, when LeBron was working,
I think, is that right, there was a blip
of six months when I bought a boatload
of basketball cards,
'cause I thought LeBron
and D Wade and Bosh and
Darko were gonna be great,
Melo, four out of five were.
And I bought a ton of
cards, but that was for,
like, five seconds, I
believe we're on the,
we're in the second
quarter of four quarters
of the sports card industry
exploding again in culture,
and I think there's a ton of money
and a lot of fun to be made
for a lot of entrepreneurs,
kids, especially sneaker kids,
who can't get enough inventory
of hard-to-get sneakers.
But if they want to go
buy 5,000 Giannis rookies,
or 400 Darko rookies, they can.
And so I'm excited because
it's something I love,
it's something I understand,
but I'm in a new era
of my life, it's not
about the million dollars
that I'll make in flipping
cards in the next three years,
and I will, it's about, it's about,
you know, the tens of thousands of kids
that I'm gonna impact, who
are gonna make 100,000 bucks
in profit in the next two years,
instead of raising a million
dollars and losing it.
And that I'm excited about, I'm excited
about pushing people,
and teaching them how
to make money, instead of raising money,
and raising money has become the sport
of entrepreneurship in
this era, not making it,
and it's something that I'm
trying to bring conversation to.
- [Maha] And the process of them having
to go through how to make that money--
- I love you, I love
you for bringing this,
I love you for saying that,
'cause you help me build
on this, 'cause I wasn't gonna go there.
The things people are gonna learn about,
human behavior, market
dynamics, supply and demand,
if you're gonna sell it on
eBay, which a lot of people are,
just even copywriting and creative.
Like, I'm really good at selling on eBay,
'cause I know how to write titles,
and I know how to take pictures
that capture people's attention,
that's why my content
does well on Instagram.
I think about titles and thumbnails.
Except on YouTube, I'm terrible at it.
- [Maha] Thank you, Gary.
- Thank you, Maha.
- A pleasure, that was really good.
I wanna amplify that
message about the human side
of business because a lot of people don't,
everyone understands the yapping CEO.
No one understands this.
- Everybody's judging
me on a surface level.
- [Maha] That's what I mean,
yeah, and that's the thing--
- And I have no interest in
pandering to the machine.
So that, I haven't done
anything to clarify it,
but what that does for
you is it gives you a--
- [Maha] That's my job, yeah.
- That gives you such
a canvas to work with,
especially when it's true.
- Yeah, I know.
- It's like, I'm like,
it's like a perfect piece
of clay for you.
- [Maha] Yeah, that's
what I'm saying, this is--
- I mean, if you fuck it up,
you're all-time terrible.
(Maha laughs)
- [Maha] Yeah, I'm not gonna let you down,
'cause I'm not gonna let myself down.
- You've, honestly, Maha,
it's no different than the,
the companies I've invested in.
I'm not guessing here,
you've already done it.
Like, it doesn't even cross my mind.
They're, I'm being dead serious with you,
like, you getting this opportunity
with me is 100% the same thing I did
with Tumblr, Facebook, and Twitter.
I didn't guess, they'd already happened.
We've already interacted enough
for me to know you do it.
- [Maha] Yeah, well, we're
just getting started.
- I'm very aware.
- [Maha] And you're very
patient, I want to do so much,
and I'm just like, okay, just.
- We will.
- [Maha] Slow and steady, and just--
- [Maha] And the fact that
I know that you aren't,
like, you know, ramming it down, like,
what's the one, like, that you are saying,
slow and steady makes me comfortable,
that I can now grow it in a way that's--
- Yeah, I mean, it's--
- [Maha] If you were putting
pressure on me, that would--
- Where's my article?
- [Maha] Yeah, that would
make me feel worse about--
- I only put pressure on
DRock, other than that.
He gets so much gold,
and just is incapable
of getting it into the marketplace.
- [Maha] When I know, like,
if you were to say to me,
do three things, then I
would just want to do 10,
you know what I mean?
- I'm sure.
- [DRock] I'm holding the camera.
- My best thing right now.
What was the thing that,
there was such a fun one.
Oh, God, it's gonna be hard to remember.
It was, like, two months
ago, like, a month ago?
Have I ever fallen, have I
ever fallen asleep on stage?
- [DRock] No.
- I'm super tired.
- [Maha] You are?
- Yeah, I haven't, I haven't slept
for 20 fucking four hours.
- [Maha] Is this our car when we finish?
- [DRock] Right, you're taking, you're--
- [Assistant] Answer to the question
for the kid about
growing the team was be--
- Mm-hmm, macro patience, micro speed.
- [Maha] Hey, you gotta--
- Operationally, operationally
you gotta go fast,
you know, theoretically,
like, what you're up to,
it makes sense.
- [Maha] That's so cool.
- That's why I'm a hard read, I'm a very,
very hard read, 'cause, like,
it is pulling from opposite directions.
It looks like it's a contradiction,
but if you think about it visually,
I'm telling you up here to go slow,
I'm telling you down here to go fast.
So people think it's all one plane,
all my content, all my
vision, everything I am,
they think it's one plane, so, like,
what the fuck, it doesn't make sense.
What they don't understand is it's this.
In real life, in the most
important shit, it's slow.
Down here, all this shit means nothing,
you have to go fast, but
people go slow down here.
Have to be thoughtful,
let's have meanings,
let's fucking over-process
it, but up here,
they're like, money now, money now.
Like, everyone's got it reversed.
Got it?
- Yup.
- Good job catching that, DRock.
- [DRock] Almost put my camera down.
- But that was a good visual to it,
that was a good way to
explain it, that's what it is.
(slow music)
- All right, why Singapore, actually?
I heard the initial plan
was to go into China first,
and then to Asia, but,
you know, why the change?
- I don't, I don't think
that's necessarily true.
You know, I think, you
know, I'm not sure where
that comes from, or, like, if I've--
(interviewer mumbles)
Or maybe, you know, to me, it's, yeah, no.
There was never the initial plan,
to me, Mainland China has
always been a far away thing,
because I know I want to do, you know,
kind of a partnership into that market,
and it'll take time to build
that kind of relationship
that would make me feel comfortable.
But Southeast Asia has been kind of
on the roadmap for at least
three years at this point.
Just, it's extremely obvious
that the growth is here,
and more importantly, 10 years ago,
I set out to build a global
communications structure,
and so it was just inevitable.
And I think some of it is circumstance,
you know, just serendipity,
but obviously it's a very, I mean,
this is maybe my fourth
or fifth trip here.
And so there's a comfort for me here,
there's comfort to do business here.
My CFO in the Publicis
holding company spent five
to seven years out here, so
there's just the familiarity,
and a lot of our global
Fortune 500 clients have
their offices here, and so
it just became very obvious.
- Are there plans to also support some
of the Singapore listed companies
that (mumbles) as well listed
on the Singapore Exchange?
- 100%, I mean, we're,
we're coming here to do business
with every single person that's interested
in doing business with us, so.
- So you're focused on what kind
of sectors you want to target?
- No, anybody who wants to
communicate to end consumers
in a B-to-B or B-to-C
environment, and recognizes
that the capability of how to do that
in the actual world we live in in 2019
and 2020 is our interest,
and that means everybody.
- You mentioned Singapore
and Southeast Asia have huge
potential, how much revenue do
you think that's gonna generate
for you, any projections?
- No.
But to try to bring new value, like,
from an ambition standpoint, you know,
we'd like to be doing, you know,
tens of millions of dollars in revenue
in the next 36 to 48 months,
'cause we think the potential
in the marketplace is here, so.
You know, because I'm
building it for myself,
you know, I think what's unusual
about VaynerMedia is, I'm not trying to,
you know, maximize profit
because I'm publicly traded.
I'm not trying to flip
it to a holding company,
so I'm not trying to maximize by EBITDA.
I'm trying to build
something that's evergreen
and in perpetuity, that I can use
for my future business behaviors.
So, as you can imagine, the short-term
or medium-term revenue
goals is not something
I'm spending any time to calculate.
It's, get established,
understand the marketplace,
understand the opportunities,
whether it's in the nuances
of American-centric digital
companies, or if it's Asian,
you know, whether it's
Line, or Cow, or, you know,
eventually WeChat or Weibo,
and things of that nature,
understand how to be the best
in the world in communicating
on where the consumer's
spending their time
in every part of the world.
- But I guess that's. (background
noise drowns out speaker)
Right, because, I mean,
unless you have a lot of cash
to flood into this region, you
have to be a bit more careful
about your strategy, maybe?
- Yeah, I mean, I think anybody
who's running a business
should always have a strategy
of not losing money, no
matter how much, you know,
I don't have the luxury
of raising capital.
So most, many businesses in today's world,
strategies are very weak,
because they're over-funded,
and they're losing money,
I don't have that luxury,
to your point.
So yeah, so I think it's a good idea
for businesses not to lose money.
- So what's your strategy
for the Singapore office?
- To take advantage of the fact
that there are very few organizations
in the entire region that
are doing proper Facebook
and Google and YouTube media
and creative executions,
just like basically every
other part of the world.
- So would you, I mean, that sounds like
what an agency does, right?
- Yeah.
- So, I mean, how are you going
to differentiate yourself?
- By being better at it, it's like--
- Can you give, like, more specific?
What do you mean by better?
- By showing clients that
making their judgment
on better should not be based
on impressions and likes,
and arbitrary brand lift studies.
It should be predicated on
the actual business results
that the company is trying to achieve.
That has been our calling card, you know,
if you are deeply in the agency world,
the majority of brands in the
world measure success based
on arbitrary reporting, headlines, awards,
or internal MMMs that are laughable.
And what we've been great at
is helping show sales lift,
or subscription growth,
or what companies are actually doing.
And so I don't say it vague, I say it kind
of the way I think about
everything in life.
I could say I'm here to swim,
and then somebody's
gonna win the gold medal
in 2020 in Tokyo, like, I
really genuinely believe
what I said, which is I think we're going
to take clients' money, and
return more business results
for them than the alternatives.
- Is that something you
guarantee to clients,
that if you don't get X results, then--
- I wish we could, I mean, there are three
to four scopes we have in the US
where we control all the
media and all the creative,
and then we do have profit sharing.
But the reason we don't do that in 90%
of scenarios is, unless
we control everything,
I'm not in a position to, you know,
guarantee when you don't
control every lever.
- So in the US, I think I
saw from a Forbes article
that clients pay a minimum
of a million US dollars,
I think it's a yearly retainer--
- Yes, that's right.
- In Singapore, how much is that gonna be?
- Zero, and what I mean by that is,
any time you enter a new market,
you have to come with enormous
humility and patience.
And so I don't have a good
enough sense of the budgets
and the appetite and the full
landscape outside the macro,
so I don't come in with
requirements in any new market,
because I think that would be audacious.
And so obviously, you know,
what we're doing is more
listening, and having real,
you know, we're 10 years deep in the US,
and we understand the landscape.
Here, my passion is to spend the first 18
to 24 months listening and
creating ad hoc executions,
and then getting our feet underneath us
to understand what the,
what the requirements
of minimum spend would be, you know,
three, four, five, six years from now.
- Okay, but isn't that also a bit risky,
that you don't really have a range
for the kind of fees
that you want to charge?
I mean, it sounds,
like, highly negotiable.
- It's short-term risky that
you could be unprofitable
within the region, but for me,
the macro business can
afford the investment,
and that's why we're doing it.
- Okay, I understand that
you also run a VC firm,
Vayner/RSE, are there any plans to take
that to Singapore, or Southeast Asia?
- Not right now, that
fund has been deployed,
actually, today's a really fun day.
We sold an incubated
company from the fund,
Resy, to American Express,
in a large acquisition
in the US, that fund
has been fully deployed.
I didn't raise another fund,
so now my investing is just
my own personal investing,
which I'm not doing a whole lot
of, 'cause I'm very head down
in operating this business.
But I am taking and have
been taking meetings
with startups in the region
because there's a lot
of interesting stuff going on.
And so there's no plans
right now, but what's great
about being an entrepreneur
is, if I decide
that there's so much
going on here that I need
to be a part of it, then I would consider
to grab some LPs, and
maybe raise some capital.
- How much, or rather, how
big is your fund right now?
- That fund was deployed, it
was a 25 million dollar fund,
and so that, all the capital's deployed,
and so I don't have an
active fund right now,
but Vayner/RSE was 25 million.
- And you no plans to raise some more?
- Not right now, no.
- Okay.
And I, I mean, your company sell,
who are your biggest investors--
- We don't, we don't have any investors.
We sold a percentage of
the company to Steve Ross,
the real estate tycoon
and owner of the Dolphins,
but my brother and I took
that capital off the table.
So we didn't raise any
capital for the company,
and if my brother didn't
want money at that time,
we probably wouldn't have
sold any piece of it.
And there's no plans to raise any capital.
- [Maha] Thank you, thank you so much--
- Gotta run?
- [Maha] One more question?
- Just the last one?
- Yep.
- Okay, so also, actually, in Singapore,
and most of the global PR industry,
there's a lot of consolidation happening.
- Yes.
- Are there any plans
to perhaps, you know,
grow your business inorganically
in Singapore or Southeast Asia?
- Meaning me doing M&A?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I think that's very realistic.
We've done some
acquisitions, we bought
a publishing company,
PureWow, a couple of years ago, and one
of the things that I am interested
in is spending time auditing
the landscape of five
to 50 person shops and
capabilities throughout the region
because I think there's a ton of talent,
and some under-priced talent.
And so I wouldn't, I
wouldn't count that out.
- So you're looking at,
say, buying another agency?
- Yes.
- Okay, any targets right now?
- No, I haven't even,
couldn't even name one agency
in any part of Asia.
- Prior to this, was there
ground research, that
you send someone to kind of
look at the landscape first,
or is this just jumping in?
- This is just jumping
in, I mean, this is,
the landscape work we've
done is the behavior
of the biggest brands in the
market on their executions
on creative and media,
against the platforms
that we feel are the
most underutilized in,
you know, and so that's
the homework we've done,
consumer behavior in the region,
what are consumers doing.
And are the brands
taking advantage of that
from a media and creative standpoint,
and once the decision made was no,
that's when it was a blind, let's go.
- And the biggest challenge for you?
- Health.
- Oh, sorry, I mean the
Singapore operations.
- Making sure the people
that run it are healthy.
- [Maha] Thank you so much.
- Awesome, thank you.
- Thank you so much.
- [Maha] We have one more, Gary.
(quiet overlapping chattering)
- Hello.
- Hi.
But firstly, I think we have to ask you,
why do you pick Singapore to
set up an office here, why--
- You know, it's my,
I'm comfortable with it.
My CFO was a CFO of a large agency here.
I've enjoyed my trips here, a lot
of my global clients' offices are here,
so actually practical,
just very practical.
A good place to do business,
and a couple serendipitous,
you know, relationships internally
that made me feel comfortable.
- So what's your
impression of Singaporeans
to work with, in general?
- Highly disciplined,
pretty entrepreneurial,
very creative, you know, the executives
on the big companies
here I think have more
entrepreneurial spirit than
I've seen in other parts
of the world, including the US.
Polite.
- Oh, wow, okay.
That's not the term always
used to describe us.
So you've really created sort
of a cult of personality,
in the sense, when you
speak across the world,
people follow you not
just for your business,
but also for your personality.
Is that something that you
consciously build up, do you?
- It's something that I
stumbled into in 2011,
'12, '13, '14 that now
I'm unbelievably aware of.
And so I think very, you know, I know
you're not gonna be able to reference it,
but I'm sure you're listening.
For me, things are very macro, you know,
very, just way up here, then I live,
then I counterpunch opportunities.
So I, I mean, I was 34
years old the first time
I gave my first speech of my
life, it never even crossed
my mind that anybody on
earth would ever know
who I was, because I was a businessman.
Then the internet comes along,
then YouTube comes along,
then I start making videos,
then I write a book,
and then all of a sudden
I'm being invited to speak.
And the first time I give a speech,
it was, (claps) I was like, oh my god,
this is, I like this, and I'm good at it.
And so you start doing it,
and then you start realizing,
maybe you're really good at it.
And then you start understanding
what it means for all your businesses
when you're building
brand, and so, you know,
now I'm very aware of what the top
of the funnel brand awareness I create
for everything I do,
whether it's sneakers,
or wine, or my agency.
So yes, and I, you know, it's interesting.
I run 1,000 person marketing
communications infrastructure,
and so it's not so easy for me to speak.
And so now I try to be very strategic
about where I speak and why,
but it also is something
I'm very aware brings a lot of value
to the overall business ecosystem.
- But when you're speaking,
you're kind of bold,
and very straightforward, and very blunt.
Is that your personality
in real life, as well,
or is that something--
- Yeah.
I think I manifest
differently in interviews
and in videos and onstage than maybe
who I am as an executive, I think I'm,
I think I'm more aggressive
when I'm not speaking
to a single human, and
I'm speaking to humans.
So I think that's where you see my most
raw part of me, and then
I think, ironically,
I'm quite the opposite
way when I'm individual.
I think my compassion and kind
of my soft skills play out
when it's a human in front
of me, versus humans.
So I think there's different
versions of all of us,
and I think it's not that it's my shtick
or my persona, it's just,
it's just how I communicate
when I'm speaking to a
general audience around macro
things.
- So you made really a name for yourself
on social media, and I
know you talked a lot
about how important social
media is in marketing--
- Yes.
- And a lot of people
are making use of it,
a lot of young people are making use of it
to become, like,
influencers, travel, food,
it's very saturated, what
do you think of that?
Do you think that trend will die out?
- I don't, I think--
- You don't?
- No, I do not, I think the
internet infrastructure allows
for KOLs and influencers at scale.
I don't think everybody's destined
to make five million dollars
a year being an influencer,
but I think what we're gonna learn is,
there's a very long tail of
it, and I think there's a lot
of practical lives to be lived that way.
Today, we view it as somebody
who makes a lot of money,
probably, to do something very extreme,
like travel and things of that nature.
I think what's exciting is
that there's a lot of people
who make $64,000.00 a year
doing something they don't love,
and I believe can make 64,000,
or let me use this example,
59,000, or 48,000 speaking
about shoes, or cars,
or hair, or wine, and will
have much happier lives
for it, and so I don't
think we've even begun
to see the long tail of
personal brands, influencers.
And I'm excited for humans,
because I think a lot
of people are gonna be happier.
- So if you, do you feel that opens
up a lot more opportunity, in that sense?
- I do, I do.
- You've kind of, you know, some people,
some influencers don't
really have strong content,
in that sense, it's just photos, and--
- But, but that's what you think.
- Okay, okay.
- You know, and I don't
think I'm right, either.
If an audience likes it, then
they like it, like, right?
Like, and so does a
model got good content?
Like, is somebody who models clothes,
making four million dollars a year,
good at what they do, I guess
so, there's a market for it.
So I don't judge if you're
funny or overly sexy,
or whatever the hell you're doing.
If an audience decides that it's good,
the audience decides, not
me, not you, and I think that
that is something that
people struggle with
because we like to impose judgment,
it is the great flaw of human beings.
I tend to let the audience decide.
I genuinely never think I'm right,
I just think I'm analyzing
an audience at all times.
And I think too many people
walk around with audacity.
- Okay, so another thing I
wanted to ask you about is
because I've heard you
talk a lot about ads,
and how you think marketing
online is really the way forward
to go, what do you think about the ethics
of marketing online, because
people are mining data
for everything, your credit card history,
browsing history, voter registration,
and that can really influence
things like elections,
for example, what do you
think of the ethics of that?
- I think humans are capable of,
of not wanting to be
accountable for their actions.
So I think that
ads
that are targeted are a hell
of a lot better than ads
that are not targeted, I prefer
that advertisers have all my information
because I do not want
to see ads for things
that I'm not interested in.
As far as
elections, those aren't
ads, that is propaganda,
and content, and humans choose to believe
what they want to believe,
people go on television
and newspapers and read the
left and the right, as well.
So I think it's very lazy
for us to blame Facebook,
or China, or things of that nature.
There's a ton of people right now
that are pumping propaganda
that 5G causes cancer,
and people choose to believe that,
or not choose to believe that.
So I think we're living through an
incredibly interesting era
where mainstream media is
desperately scared of
the new media platforms,
and so they're pumping a lot
of interesting information
that is molding people's decisions.
But as for me, I'd prefer
that advertisers had all
my information, because I'm not worried
about them knowing about my credit score,
or my preferences of fruit,
or bicycles, or clothes.
I think people love to talk about privacy,
but don't actually believe it.
- What do you mean by
they don't believe it?
- I don't think people care about privacy.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- You've got Russia and China
citizens living life knowing
they have no privacy at the macro,
you have naive Americans
thinking they did have it,
and ultimately, nobody gives a crap.
You're more than welcome
to not put your information
on the internet, you don't
like it, don't use the apps.
Instagram's not making you do anything,
WeChat's not making you do anything.
People don't want to be accountable
for their actions, so it's easier
to blame big internet companies,
versus blaming yourself.
- Too true, so in the sense,
Singapore audience is a bit,
you've worked in the US
for, like, 10 years, right?
But the Singapore audience
is quite different from,
the demographics is quite different.
So do you think how you might, you know,
marketing to Singaporeans, as well,
some of the concerns that
you suspect you have to--
- There's no concerns, I think, you know,
and I think you'll appreciate this.
There's 17,000 different
Singaporean audiences,
psychographic, demographic, experiences,
there's no American audience,
I think the world's starting
to realize there's two
very different Americas,
and then there's 50 different Americans
underneath those two different Americas.
What's amazing about humans
is they have many truths,
and then all you have to do
is be culturally relevant.
So being able to synthesize the pulse
of a 26-year-old Singaporean
single female takes research
and development, and testing of creative.
I don't come in with
opinions, I come in listening
and reacting, it doesn't take very long,
if you're willing to listen,
so I go into every market very
easily, I just listen, and then I talk.
- So what advice would you have for people
who are looking to make
it using the media,
whether they be influencers, or people
who are using the media to sell something?
- By trying not to sell something.
- Oh, okay.
- I think the biggest way to
actually build an audience
and create leverage is to
bring value, not extract it.
And I think one of the biggest reasons
so many people will not be influencers is
they are sitting right now, thinking,
I'm gonna start this page,
and these people are gonna pay
me, or brands are gonna pay
me to put something in
front of these people.
But I haven't brought any
value to these people yet,
so I don't have any
leverage to put this bottle
of coffee, or this T-shirt.
And I think the reason you saw
so many people win four years ago was
they didn't realize they were influencers,
they were just posting their
passions and interests,
and they built an audience,
and then they leveraged it.
Now you've got a whole generation
who wants to be influencers from day one,
so their intent in making
the content is to monetize,
which we feel as an audience,
thus we don't give them
our attention, and so
the number one strategy
and the number one piece
of advice I have is,
actually bring value to your audience
before you ever think about monetizing it.
- So would you ever think
of moving to Singapore?
Some people have moved to
Singapore after speaking here,
for example.
- Yeah.
Definitely not, but that's
only because I'm so in love
with New York, I can't even
move out of New York City
to the suburbs of New York City.
So I don't think that's
in the cards for me,
but I'm unbelievably excited
to spend a lot of time here.
Every trip is better than the last one,
as I continue to get to know
the city and the people,
and obviously now we've
created a structure
that's gonna force me
to be here quite a bit,
and so I'm really excited about that.
- So where do you hang out
when you come to Singapore?
- Wherever your meetings are.
- Oh, okay.
- So I'm not living a, I'm not living a,
I'm living a business life here.
So I haven't begun, I don't even hang out
in New York City, let alone anytime,
so I don't, to me, it's
wherever the meeting is,
hotel lobbies, restaurants that clients
or friends or startups
want me to go check out.
But it's not been anything
of, like, thought.
- Oh, so you haven't actually
gone out exploring the food
or the sites or anything like that?
- I've never done that anywhere ever.
- [Maha] We need to wrap up,
we have to do some book signings.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
Do you have one more question?
- Yeah, I know you are
in the wine business?
- Yes.
- So I just wanted to ask
you if you're planning
to bring that here, or.
- We are, we actually
teamed up with Vinomofo,
V-I-N-O-M-O-F-O, and we
actually can sell in Singapore.
We're selling in Australia, New Zealand,
and Singapore, so I'm
pretty excited about that.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- Thank you so much.
- [Photographer] Okay,
sir, just a quick photo?
- Yes.
- [Photographer] Just stay there.
- Yep.
- [Photographer] (mumbles) here.
(shutter clicks)
Look down a little bit.
(overlapping chattering)
Great, thank you.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
You're welcome.
- All right, thank you so much.
- You're welcome, sign?
- [Maha] Yeah.
- [Gary] Thank you, guys,
thank you for your time.
(overlapping chattering)
(quiet overlapping chattering)
- [Danny] Gary (mumbles) his book signing.
- I, this is something I've got down now.
- [Danny] You're crushing it. (laughs)
- Danny, thank you for your time.
- [Danny] Sorry?
- Thank you so much.
- [Danny] Oh, you're most welcome,
Gary, you're most welcome.
(quiet overlapping chattering)
- Okay, there.
One more allowed?
Thanks a lot.
- Fantastic.
- Thanks again, thanks for doing this.
- Thank you, all the best, cheers.
(quiet overlapping chattering)
- You guys are the best,
it's like an operation here.
(quiet overlapping chattering)
Thank you.
- [Danny] Could we stand on
two of these for the report?
(overlapping chattering)
- What's that?
- Can I take a picture--
- Picture, yes, yes.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Danny] Thank you so much for that.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
I really do appreciate
it, it's been a pleasure.
(overlapping chattering)
- Thank you so much, friend.
- Thank you, you got it.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Danny] Thank you, everyone.
- [Maha] Thank you, everybody.
- Thank you, guys.
- [Maha] Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Assistant] Push back about 10 minutes,
or are we fine for time?
- Am I gonna be 50 then?
(overlapping chattering)
- No, but you've, they
told me to do 45 and 15,
45, too, I mean, for
that keynote, 15 minutes.
(overlapping chattering)
So what we're shooting
here is 15 second swipe ups
for all the markets, so we have the list.
Simon will take lead on
how he wants to put it,
and then just one 45 second piece
that's just gonna be him commenting--
- So we'll cut it, yeah, so if we,
if you can keep a mark, make sure we stay
on the same page, so what
we'll do is we'll just go,
hey, Sydney, hey, Brisbane--
- I get it.
- And then we'll cut it, yeah, so if we--
- What do you want me?
- Finally got your spot, you happy there?
- Yeah, I'm happy with it.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Simon] If I'll just get
a testing, testing going.
- One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine.
- Cool.
All right, so we'll
start off by just running
with the cities, so hey Sydney, then--
- Melbourne, Brisbane,
Auckland, London, Dubai, India.
(quiet overlapping chattering)
- We'll do, hey, India,
and hey, Bangalore,
just 'cause that's where, just to cover--
- [Photography Assistant]
And then also Russia,
Saint Petersburg.
- We'll do it all, just.
- All right.
- Hey, Sydney.
So just, that's all you want, right?
- [Simon] Yeah, just say Sydney,
then we'll go to the next one.
- Hey, Sydney, hey,
Melbourne, hey, Brisbane.
Hey, Auckland, hey,
London, what up, Dubai.
Hey, Dubai, hey, India,
what's the other one?
- There was a, hey, Bangalore, as well.
- Hey, Bangalore.
- Russia and Saint Petersburg.
- Two separate ones?
- Yeah, hey, Russia, and
then, hey, Saint Petersburg.
- Hey, Russia, hey, Saint Petersburg.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Cool, all right, stand on your mark,
and then it's, so this is
gonna be for the swipe up,
so try and keep them under 15 seconds.
So a quick spiel, guys,
I'm coming to see you,
however you want to word it.
Less than 10 seconds,
and then we'll land on,
well, that's it, just give
them a quick speil for--
- You're cutting the
first part, adding this,
swiping up, right?
- Well, at the end we're
gonna go, so swipe up.
- Yep.
- So that's gonna be a third section,
so this is now the middle section,
so about eight, nine
seconds would be ideal.
- Understood, and you're
gonna use the same one
for all of them?
- Exactly.
- Understood, do you want
me to finish the whole way
through, this way you don't have to edit.
- If you want to, okay, we'll do that,
and then we'll do it again
for, click on the links.
So swipe up--
- We'll see it through.
- (mumbles) swipe up, and
then spiel, click link.
- Spiel all, got it, so.
Do you want me to just do the spiel,
and then later we'll do the click, and?
- Let's just do a little take now, yeah.
So we'll do all the swipe ups
first, so spiel, swipe up,
and then spiel, click link,
we'll do that afterwards.
- I'm coming to bring
the great communications
and entrepreneurial keynote to your city.
Swipe up to find out now.
- [Simon] Perfect.
- Okay.
- [Simon] Now the click link.
- I'm coming to give
you the content you need
to run your business
and to market perfectly
in today's day, click now.
- [Simon] Perfect, now
let's do just a big,
a generic spiel for what
you're gonna be bringing
to each city, but--
- I can go long, 45 seconds?
- [Simon] Yeah.
- Guys, I'm so excited to
be coming to your town.
Really, I'm gonna be
giving a state of the union
of where we are in
entrepreneurship and marketing.
For me, the last 25 years of
my career have been predicated
in a very simple game of, do
I know how to run a business,
and do I know how to
market to the consumer
in the way they consume content today.
I'll bring you the tips, the tricks,
and the execution needed
to win today's day.
- [Simon] Cool.
(overlapping chattering)
Let's do, price on tickets is
going up today, so act now.
- Prices on the tickets are
- [Simon] Cool, so how was all of that?
So do you want to do 2B57?
- [Man In Suit] No,
leave that there, done.
- [Simon] Cool, all right,
thank you, mate, appreciate it,
easy.
- I mean, it's a whole lot
of practice that goes into that.
- [Simon] Yeah.
- [Production Assistant] I'm ready.
- So we're gonna do a drop for.
- Okay.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
Okay.
- So if you need anything,
you just let me know
to make yourself more comfortable.
- [Gary] Thank you, I'm great.
- [Production Assistant] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(slow pop music)
- [Miles] You know what, while we're here,
let me get a shot with you, bro.
- You got it, bro.
- Let's do it.
I didn't know you were this tall,
I thought you was real short, bro.
- Thank you, I'll take it.
- Awesome, that's--
- Thank you, bro.
- I'm serious, I thought you were shorter.
I meet a lot of people
and they're really short,
but they look tall on TV, you look tall--
- Good, good, I appreciate it.
(overlapping chattering)
- [DRock] I prayed, I prayed for,
what are the odds?
- What's that?
- [DRock] No, he was just
saying, another guy has--
- [Assistant] Someone else
has the same color shirt
that he has in this room.
- Never, I.
(overlapping chattering)
What?
Yeah, so I'm in Singapore, super excited
to give this talk on,
yeah, we've been running it,
like, completely misplayed
my flight from LA
to Singapore, slept for
six and a half hours,
and I just stayed up,
looking up sports cards
on eBay the whole way, paying,
like, $8,000.00 in wifi.
So probably the most tired
I've ever been going onstage,
which probably sets up,
like, a great, yeah, like--
(DRock mumbles)
I feel the adversity is
gonna bring a great talk.
So we're just gonna, we're
gonna drop our knowledge,
see what happens.
(slow electronic music)
(overlapping chattering)
I just want to get everybody.
- All right, so here's
what we're gonna do.
Everyone will get content,
we want you guys to do is,
we want you guys to
put all of your energy,
we're getting ready to
take a photo real quick
with all the speakers who are lined up,
and also everyone here,
so we're gonna have our.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
A quick little selfie, so if
you guys can kind of stand up,
(mumbles) while we take
this photo really quick,
and then we're gonna
bring more things to do.
(overlapping chattering)
(slow music)
♪ Oh, sometimes I feel real deep, yeah ♪
♪ I gotta figure out,
out, out, how I feel ♪
♪ No, no, gotta be, yeah ♪
- [Photographer] Okay,
look here, one, two,
three, smile, one more time.
- We're now gonna take,
do things with Gary Vee.
Also, I want put something
on the screen here,
all the speakers today gave you
a lot of great content, yes?
(audience cheers)
So I know you guys probably
didn't have the opportunity
to write everything down,
so what we have flashed
on the screen right
here is a piece of art,
they covered all the content,
and it's a real easy-to-learn,
easy way to gain information,
so it's up there real quick.
But I want you to put
this thing in your heads,
June 12, say, June 12.
- [Audience] June 12.
- Success Resource will email
you all the information,
and give you, check
your email for content,
and they'll share with you,
and guess how much it costs?
It's free, the only thing
it costs is your time
to come learn how to do
this, so that you can be able
to write down notes
fairly quick, good stuff?
- [Audience] Yes.
- All right, so now,
we're gonna do something
really cool here, we're
going to do a closing song.
- [Maha] Wow.
(audience cheers)
(overlapping chattering)
("The Power of the Dream" by Celine Dion)
At least we got the words.
Oh, it's this song.
("The Power of the Dream" by Celine Dion)
♪ Deep within each heart ♪
♪ There lies a magic ♪
♪ That lights ♪
- Aren't you singing?
♪ That lights the fire
of our imagination ♪
♪ And since the dawn of man ♪
♪ The strength of just I can ♪
♪ Has brought together people of all ♪
♪ Nations ♪
♪ There's nothing ordinary ♪
♪ In the living of each day ♪
♪ There's a special part
every one of us will play ♪
♪ Feel the flame forever burn ♪
♪ Teaching lessons we must learn ♪
♪ To bring us closer to
the power of the dream ♪
♪ As the world gives us its best ♪
♪ To stand apart from all the rest ♪
♪ It is the power of the
dream that brings us here ♪
♪ Your mind will take you far ♪
♪ The rest is just your heart ♪
♪ You'll find your fate
is all your own creation ♪
♪ And every boy and girl ♪
♪ As they come into this world ♪
♪ They bring the gift of
hope and inspiration ♪
♪ Feel the flame forever burn ♪
♪ Teaching lessons we must learn ♪
♪ To bring us closer to
the power of the dream ♪
♪ The world unites in hope and peace ♪
♪ We pray that you will always be ♪
♪ It is the power of the dream ♪
♪ That brings us here ♪
- All right, wasn't that good?
(audience applauds)
Well, now we're getting ready to close,
but we're gonna start from this side
with the words of wisdom
to close out with you guys.
- Actually, my name is Ken, I work
for the Success Resources, the notes
that you saw onscreen were done by me,
and it's our gift to you, and we'd love
to teach you how to do it yourself,
so enjoy the slides June 12th.
(overlapping chattering)
- Hi, everybody, Scott
again, my philosophy is,
for us to become somebody
we've never been,
we have to be able to do
something we've never done.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, my name is Michael,
I'm the Director of Success Resources.
I've been doing this for 16
years alongside these guys,
and I was a part of the team
who put the 25 year NAC
Tour Anniversary together,
and what's special about
that is, 25 years ago,
these guys created the first NAC.
About 25 years later,
we're starting it here
in Singapore again, and we're
taking this around the world.
I want to say a thank you
for being a part of it,
I want to say thank you to
Gary for being a part of that,
as well, and to Richard Vorinko
for making this dream happen.
Thanks, guys.
(audience cheers)
(panel applauds)
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
Now, this event would not
have happened if it's not
for the team, so I want
all of us to help me
to thank the team, who's
all in the back of the room,
just clap.
(audience applauds)
Thanks all of you in the team.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
And thank all of you for surely coming,
so keep doing, okay, thank you, bye bye.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
- I got you.
- There's one guy in the
room, other than anybody else,
none other than our MC, Miles,
so let's give him a big
hand, thank you, Miles.
(audience applauds)
And there's a lot of people
doing this, so let's,
another big hand.
(audience applauds)
(background noise drowns out speaker)
So we are always, we are always
looking for people to serve
and the best way, the Protege
Program, all plays a part.
Before I pass this to Gary
for the last, last final word,
I (mumbles) and each
and every one of you is,
is fight for your dream, and
your dream will fight for you.
Don't stop when you're
tired, stop only when it is?
- [Audience] Done.
- Done, thank you.
- Yeah.
(audience applauds)
- Good.
Thank you for listening to the keynote,
I'm really, really just very
grateful for your attendance
and attention, look, the
odds of being a human being,
currently, by modern scientists,
is 400 trillion to one.
The fact that you are even a person is
so ridiculously impossible,
you have one life,
please do something with it, thank you.
- Thank you.
(audience cheers)
- All right, all the
platinum and diamonds,
make your way into the
diamond, thank you, guys.
(overlapping chattering)
(upbeat music)
- [Photographer] Gary?
- [Gary] Yes?
- [Photographer] Let's
do one picture with--
- [Gary] Yes.
Yes, with everybody?
(upbeat music)
- [Photographer] Just smile.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
(upbeat music)
- [Maha] Thank you.
- Okay, you're awesome.
- Thank you, brother.
- Everybody's waiting for you.
(upbeat music)
♪ Looking for a better
way to get up out of bed ♪
♪ Instead of getting on the internet ♪
♪ And checking out who hit me, get up ♪
♪ Thrift shop, pimp strut walking ♪
♪ Little bit of humble,
little bit of cautious ♪
♪ Somewhere between like Rocky and Cosby ♪
♪ Sweater game, nope,
nope y'all can't copy ♪
♪ Yup, bad ♪
- [Maha] Thank you so much.
♪ This here is our party ♪
♪ Our posse's been on Broadway ♪
♪ And we did it our way, grown music ♪
♪ I shed my skin and put my bones ♪
♪ Into everything I record to it ♪
♪ And yet I'm on ♪
♪ Let that stage light go ♪
- [Production Assistant] Careful.
♪ Shine on down ♪
♪ Got that Bob Barker suit
game and plinko in my style ♪
♪ Money, stay on my craft and
stick around for those pounds ♪
♪ But, I do that to pass the
torch and put on for my town ♪
♪ Trust me, on my
I-N-D-E-P-E-N-D-E-N-T shit ♪
♪ Hustling, chasing
dreams since I was 14 ♪
♪ With the four track busing ♪
♪ Halfway cross that
city with the backpack ♪
♪ Fat cat, crushing labels out here ♪
♪ No, they can't tell me nothing ♪
♪ We give that to the people ♪
♪ Spread it across the country ♪
♪ Labels out here ♪
♪ No, they can't tell me nothing ♪
♪ We give it to the people ♪
♪ Spread it across the country ♪
♪ Can we go back, this is the moment ♪
♪ Tonight is the night,
we'll fight till it's over ♪
♪ So we put our hands up like
the ceiling can't hold us ♪
♪ Like the ceiling can't hold us ♪
- [Man In Blue Jacket]
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
♪ Now can I kick it, thank you ♪
♪ Yeah, I'm so damn grateful ♪
♪ I grew up, really wanted gold fronts ♪
♪ But that's what you get
when Wu-Tang raised you ♪
♪ Y'all can't stop me ♪
♪ Go hard like I got 808 in my heartbeat ♪
♪ And I'm eating at the beat
like you gave a little speed ♪
♪ To a great white shark on Shark Week ♪
♪ We raw, time to go off, I'm gone ♪
♪ Deuces goodbye, I got a world to see ♪
♪ And my girl, she wanna see Rome ♪
♪ Caesar make you a believer ♪
♪ No, I never ever did it for a throne ♪
♪ That validation comes from
giving it back to the people ♪
♪ No, sing a song and it goes like this ♪
♪ Raise those hands, this is our party ♪
♪ We came here to live life
like nobody was watching ♪
♪ I got my city right behind
me, if I fall, they got me ♪
♪ Learn from that failure, gain humility ♪
♪ And then we keep marching I said ♪
♪ Can we go back, this is the moment ♪
♪ Tonight is the night,
we'll fight till it's over ♪
♪ So we put our hands up like
the ceiling can't hold us ♪
♪ Like the ceiling can't hold us ♪
♪ Can we go back, this is the moment ♪
♪ Tonight is the night,
we'll fight till it's over ♪
♪ So we put our hands up like
the ceiling can't hold us ♪
(overlapping chattering)
(upbeat music)
♪ So we put our hands up ♪
- [Gary] I got it, it's signed.
(overlapping chattering)
(slow music)
- Thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome, brother.
- [Fan] Thank you so much.
- [Gary] You're welcome,
thank you for coming.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Miles] All right,
guys, we want everybody
to head over to the
platinum and diamond lounge.
You got your ticket, get
ready to work your way over
to the platinum and diamond lounge.
- Thank you.
- You got it.
(upbeat music)
(overlapping chattering)
Hi.
I hope so.
- Nice.
- Thank you for coming.
(overlapping chattering)
♪ Can we go back, this is the moment ♪
♪ Tonight is the night ♪
- [Gary] You're welcome.
(overlapping chattering)
We gotta go?
Whose is this?
(overlapping chattering)
You're welcome.
- Let's get you de-mic'd.
- You got it.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Production Assistant]
All right, 30 seconds.
- [Gary] Yes.
(overlapping chattering)
(upbeat music)
- So this is the question
I gotta ask, man.
I lead with the heart, I
do breakthrough summits,
and the biggest thing is that
I really overcame the abuse
with my father as a young
boy, and I faced him as a man.
And that breakthrough has
allowed me to be more authentic,
more real with people, and now
I'm taking that same message.
And when you said, "Most
of the problems happen
"with the parents," yes, that was so true.
And it's been, it was affecting
everything in my life.
- Everything.
- I was successful, but
there was something missing,
and that was that insecurity
and the love I didn't get
from them.
- That's right.
- So how do I go about
continuously sharing that message,
but allowing my dad not
to feel the way he felt?
But we shared that moment, but
I want to take it public now,
and just let him know that I love him,
it was true what happened, I forgave him,
and now I'm gonna share it publicly.
- You just crushed that,
you say that to him,
and then you hedge it up
front every time you go there.
You make it clear, I do the same thing,
listen, there was a lot of friction
for me and my dad, too,
but I make it very clear
that I love him with all my heart.
Not everything was perfect,
not everything's perfect
with anybody, but you're
right, that truth.
- Yeah.
- Like, it took me 10
years to even mention
that my mom's dad went to
jail for 10 years in Russia,
'cause everybody Jewish had it, you know?
Like, we're always growing
into sharing more truths,
and so that's how you do it,
hedge it, hedge it up front,
so it doesn't make your dad feel terrible,
but it still gives everybody the truth.
- [Miles] Man, I appreciate that.
- [Gary] You got it,
brother, see you later.
- [Miles] Later.
- All right, where we
going, thank you, everyone.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Man In Red] Gary.
- Yes?
- Remember me?
- Yes, I do, it's good to
see you, how have you been?
- [Man In Red] I promise
you, it's ready, the--
- It's ready?
- [Man In Red] The artist proof.
- Oh, man.
- This is for you to sign.
- [Gary] Oh, thank you so much.
- [Man In Red] Here, and I sign, and then.
- [Gary] Dude, that's amazing.
- I don't want you want to do, but.
- Oh, there it is, yes.
- It's all here, minis
for Tyler, Caesar, and--
- [Gary] It's fucking amazing.
- And Tyler got the most photos.
- Yes.
- DRock's again.
- What can I do, sign?
- Sign here.
Then it kind of, like, six months ago,
what we wanted to do, we're gonna do it
with this signature together, yeah.
(overlapping chattering)
- Thank you so much, brother.
Sign it?
- Sign it, just sign it.
Thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
- So it's all here.
- [Gary] Dude, I'm so proud of you, dude.
- [Man In Red] Thank you--
- [Gary] You're really doing it.
- [Man In Red] (mumbles)
in Indonesia, right?
- [Gary] What's that?
- [Man In Red] Paxton from Salling Group?
Yeah, he told me about.
- Yes, I'm so proud of you,
dude, to keep this family,
like, I need this.
(overlapping chattering)
- Which is the third generation--
- I know, I know, I know,
it's good to see you, bro.
You've been well?
- I'm good, I'm good.
- Hi, Gary, can you (mumbles) this sign?
- Yes.
- Can we take a photo?
- We can.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
- [Man In Red] This is 3D office.
- [Sherman] Hi, Gary, I'm
Sherman, nice to meet you.
- So nice to meet you, how are you?
- [Man In Red] He did the 3D rendering,
I send to Thailand.
(overlapping chattering)
- Thank you so much, okay, real quick.
- [Director] We've got
to (mumbles) right here,
come on here, please.
- You ready?
- [Director] No, no, no.
- [Maha] Gary, we just want to get a photo
with him, with you.
- [Gary] Yes, okay, one second.
(overlapping chattering)
- [DRock] One, two, five.
- Sorry.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Man In Red] Thanks, Gary.
- [Gary] So proud of you,
brother, it's great to see you.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Woman In Black Blazer] Thank you.
- [Masha] Hey, Gary, what's up?
- [Gary] Hi, I love that you snuck out--
- [Masha] Say something
nice, my name is Masha.
(overlapping chattering)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Director] Yeah, fast, please.
(slow electronic music)
(overlapping chattering)
- Okay, so we'll do this
quick, easy, and fast.
Fast. (speaking in foreign language)
Gary needs to catch a
flight, 'cause he needs to be
in (mumbles) quickly, so there's
one official photographer.
You can pick up your
photos on the website link
that we will give to you,
it will be really quick,
no personal photos, no
selfies, so a really quick one.
And then off the stage,
Gary, off the stage,
and then we'll get through
everybody really quickly.
Can we do this, okay, thank you so much.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Gary] You're welcome, right there?
- [Miles] Most of this rather
quickly, and I'm gonna be
directing traffic, so you
come up, take your photo.
- [Production Assistant] Thank you, Gary.
- [Miles] Say goodbye.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Miles] One camera.
- [Production Assistant] Nice to see you,
thank you.
- Good to see you.
- [Director] If they're
taking a long time,
Gary, don't sign.
- Okay.
- [Director] No signing.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Anthony] Just a quick
one, that's all, so Anthony.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Photographer] One, two, three, wait.
- Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
- It's a natural reaction.
- I know, I'm gonna go.
- Next, please?
(overlapping chattering)
- Thank you for your question.
Of course.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Photographer] All right,
one, two, three, okay.
- So next, please.
- Congratulations.
- [Fan] Thank you.
- [Gary] Pleasure.
- [Fan] Love you.
- [Gary] Love you back.
- [Photographer] One, two, three.
- Thank you very much.
- So nice to see you.
- [Gym Owner] Hey, man, a pleasure.
- Thank you so much for your question.
- I own a gym in Indonesia,
can I be your trainer
for free when you're here?
- Send me an email, put it in the title.
- This is for you, man.
- Thank you so much, Steve?
- [Fan] Can we do a show down?
- [Gary] We can.
- [Fan] Like this.
- [Gary] I got it.
- [Fan] So I was trying
to be an MME fighter.
- [Gary] Good for you, awesome.
- [Fan] Thank you, I'm
so inspired, thank you.
- [Photographer] Next, please.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Gary] How are you, good to see you.
Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
(speaking in foreign language)
- All right, next, please?
- How are you?
- Hi.
(overlapping chattering)
- Awesome, take care.
- What's up?
- How are you?
- Yeah, good.
- [Photographer] One, two, three.
(overlapping chattering)
- Nice to meet you.
How are you?
- All right.
- [Photographer] One, two, three.
- Oh, awesome (mumbles).
- Thank you, thank you, brother,
it's good to see you, hi.
- [Fan In Red Dress] This
one, they make a movie based
on my life story, so I
already sign for you.
- [Gary] I love it, thank you.
- [Fan In Red Dress] Thank you.
- Thank you for coming.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- How are you, brother?
- How are you, man?
- Looking sharp, bro.
- (mumbles) it's nice to see you, man.
- Thank you so much, thank
you, I hope you enjoyed.
- Hey, Gary, here's your painting.
- Man, that's amazing, dude.
- You like it?
- I like it a lot.
- Yeah, you can--
- It's incredible.
Yeah, of course.
(overlapping chattering)
Great work.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much, put
out content for them,
not for the funnel, then it will come.
- [Painter] Okay, sure.
(overlapping chattering)
- I get some energy from you.
- Cool, such a pleasure.
(overlapping chattering)
(speaking in foreign language)
- It's always a. (mumbles)
- [Photographer] One, two, three.
- So good to see you, brother, thank you.
Thank you so much, brother.
(overlapping chattering)
- Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
(man in black shirt mumbles)
Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
Such a pleasure.
- Thank you so much.
- Take care.
- Hi, Gary Vee, I'd love to
work for you at VaynerMedia.
- Is this a real, I gotta go check it out.
- [Photographer] One, two, three.
(overlapping chattering)
- I have a T-shirt for you.
- Thank you, yeah, I'll take it, Steve?
- Gary, thank you very
much for everything.
- Thank you for those kind
words, sorry for your loss.
- [Woman In Yellow] It's hard, but hey.
- [Gary] The problem is
there's no alternatives, right,
you just gotta move.
- You're a blessing in
disguise, thank you so much.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
How are you?
Thank you for coming, I hope you enjoyed.
- Thank you very much, thank you--
- Thanks for shaking your
head at the right moments,
I noticed you in the crowd, you know,
sometimes you see somebody who gets it,
I saw you.
- Thank you very much.
Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- My man.
- So quantity, or quality content?
- Both.
(overlapping chattering)
You can do both.
- Really?
- 'Cause nobody gets to decide quality.
- Okay, but if you are to do it every day.
- But if the audience
likes it, it is quality.
- Okay.
- You understand?
Don't let your insecurities
disguise as perfection,
decide quantity or
quality, do you understand?
- How you doing?
- Hi.
- Great to meet you.
- Such a pleasure.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- Thank you so--
- Hope you enjoyed, take care.
- Gary, my man.
- How are you?
- I'm good.
- It's a pleasure.
- I've been touched by your
message about the kids.
- Thank you.
- I'll DM you.
- Please.
- Let's work together.
(overlapping chattering)
- Thank you so much.
- You take care now.
Have a good trip.
- You too.
Have a great day.
- Hello, Gary Vee.
- How are you, bro, good to see you.
- Thank you, thank you for coming here.
(overlapping chattering)
- It's great to be here.
- Thank you so much.
- Take care of yourself.
(overlapping chattering)
- Hi, Gary.
- Hi.
- Thanks for coming down.
- Thank you.
Thanks for saying that.
(overlapping chattering)
I hope you enjoy.
- Thanks, I did.
(overlapping chattering)
- We're going up, we're going
together, brother and sister.
- Let's do it, such a pleasure.
- Thanks for coming on
focus, it was really good.
- That makes me happy, yeah,
I saw you guys reacting--
- Thanks, man.
- Thanks.
- Yeah, good luck.
- Cheers.
(overlapping chattering)
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome so much.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- Take care.
- Have fun.
- Thank you, my friend.
- I'm one of the old fuckers, Gary.
- Hey, I get it, me too,
brother, it's great to see you.
(overlapping chattering)
I hope you enjoyed it.
- I did, fantastic.
- Thank you.
- Keep up the good work.
(overlapping chattering)
- Hi.
- How are you?
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you so much, brother, take care.
How are you?
- Gary Vee.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you so much.
- Can you take a photo with my new book--
- You got it.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you.
- Okay, thank you.
- Thank you, take care.
(overlapping chattering)
- How are you?
- Thanks, Gary.
- You're welcome.
(overlapping chattering)
I hope you enjoyed.
- Yeah, I did.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for your answer,
man.
- You're welcome.
- I brought you one of my books.
- Thank you.
- As a gift.
- [Photographer] One, two, three.
- I want to hug you.
- Please.
Have a great day.
- Thank you.
- You smell great.
(overlapping chattering)
- How are you?
Thank you.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- Hi.
- Gary, you've changed my life.
- Thank you, that makes
me so happy, you well?
- [Photographer] One, two, three.
- I hope you enjoyed today.
- Yes, I did.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- Here you go, man.
- How are you, brother?
- [Man With Badge] I'm good.
- [Photographer] One, two, three.
(overlapping chattering)
- Thank you for coming.
- Thanks, man.
(overlapping chattering)
- Hey, man, hi.
- How are you?
- Good.
- I hope you enjoyed.
Yes, of course.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you for coming, take care.
How are you, a pleasure.
(overlapping chattering)
I hope you enjoyed.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, take care.
(overlapping chattering)
(speaking in foreign language)
Hi.
- Hi.
- How are you guys, how are you?
How you doing?
- Good, good, I'm good.
(overlapping chattering)
Can you do a quick sign?
- Yes, you got a pen?
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you.
- Bye bye.
- Bye.
(overlapping chattering)
- Hi, thank you so much.
- Hi, you're welcome.
- [Photographer] Okay, one, two, three.
- Thank you for coming.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- Hi, Gary, nice meeting you--
- It's a pleasure.
Thank you so much.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you for coming.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- Real good, thank you.
- Pleasure.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you for coming.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- Nice to meet you, man.
- Nice to meet you, bro.
How are you?
- Great.
Thanks for all the tactics,
we're running good companies.
(overlapping chattering)
- Makes me happy, take care.
- Gary, I'm from Taiwan, this is your--
- Thank you.
- I'll pass it.
- And really, thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(speaking in foreign language)
I will.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you, my friend, thank you.
- Hi, Gary, nice to know you.
- How are you?
- I'm good.
- Thanks for coming.
- Thank you for coming.
(overlapping chattering)
- You enjoyed?
- Yeah.
Sure, of course, very much.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- Nice to meet you.
- So nice to meet you.
- Oh, yes.
- You enjoyed?
- Yes, very, very much.
(overlapping chattering)
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
- Okay.
(overlapping chattering)
- Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- Great.
- Pleasure.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you.
- Thank you, Gary.
(overlapping chattering)
- Hi.
- How are you?
- Nice meeting you, man.
- Real pleasure.
(overlapping chattering)
I hope you enjoyed.
- Yeah, I enjoyed very much.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
Hi, brother, how are you?
- Not bad.
- So good to see you.
(overlapping chattering)
I hope you enjoyed.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- How are you, so good, good to see you.
- Good to see you.
(overlapping chattering)
- I hope you enjoyed the keynote.
- Thank you.
- Thank you, take care.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Man Wearing Glasses] Good to see you.
- Thank you so much, I hope you enjoyed.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you so much, thank you for coming.
- Gary, she's our GM in
China, she's the chair
of the China market.
- Thank you,
how are you?
- So I was thinking,
yeah, very well, so I was thinking--
- We are thinking of bringing
you to Japan, or (mumbles).
- Oh, fantastic.
- You've been in China, maybe,
because I want to find
out a little bit more
about your China set, how you do it.
- Happy to talk to you about it.
- Yeah, okay.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you.
- Okay, thank you.
- Such a pleasure to meet you.
(overlapping chattering)
Hi.
- I came from Russia, you
know you're coming to Russia--
- I know.
- I'm so excited.
(overlapping chattering)
(speaking in foreign language)
- Yes, so we'll see you soon,
we heard you're doing (mumbles)
Masterminds, so we wanted
to invite you to do
something during together--
- Okay, let's talk, please.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Man In Blue Suit] Yeah,
he speaks Russian, huh?
- Uh-huh.
- What's going on, man?
- How are you, brother?
- Very good, very good, man.
(overlapping chattering)
I'm gonna be helping you a
lot in Russia and Kazakhstan.
- I can't wait.
- Business (mumbles) successful--
- Awesome.
(overlapping chattering)
- Look forward to seeing--
- Looking forward to it.
- What you're doing, man.
- Thank you, brother.
- Hi.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Gary] How are you?
- Very good.
- Good.
(overlapping chattering)
Great to see you again.
- Great to see you again.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Gary] What's been going on?
- I've been busy with my podcast.
I just recently did
one with Grant Cardone.
- I love it.
- Yeah.
- It's great.
- So I'm thinking of,
how do I scale it up,
like, scale the podcast
to do more downloads, and et cetera?
- Instagram story ads.
- Instagram story ads?
- Against people that
follow other entrepreneurs.
- Okay.
- It will work.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- He's our partner for--
- And when you do that, you swipe,
swipe up to your subscribe page.
(overlapping chattering)
The ad, you say, swipe
up to listen, got it?
When you have Grant on,
you target fans of Grant.
(overlapping chattering)
- Gotta talk with another people.
- How are you?
- [Woman In Plaid Pants]
Russia, from Poland.
- Such a pleasure.
- [Man In Pink Shirt] Please
come, nice to meet you.
- So nice to meet you, how are you?
- [Woman In Plaid Pants] We
want to invite you to Poland.
- Let's go, I'm super into it, I mean,
it's very close, let's go right now.
- [Man In Pink Shirt] Next year, yeah?
- I would love to.
(overlapping chattering)
- No, maybe this year.
- Such a pleasure.
- Why not?
- I'm, listen, it's
very close to Babruysk,
you know, it's like my,
back of my neighborhood.
- Yeah, we'll take you
on a date with Lenny.
- Awesome.
(overlapping chattering)
- Hi, Gary, this is a
dream come true to see you.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- You inspire me to document my life.
- [Man In Ball Cap] Big deal.
- Thank you, brother.
(overlapping chattering)
It makes me very happy, take care.
- Give me a hug.
- You got it, brother.
- [Man In Ball Cap] Thank you.
- You're welcome very much.
- Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- I love you, Gary.
- I love you back, brother.
(overlapping chattering)
Good to see you.
- I already took a photo with you.
- I'm aware.
- So I just want to ask you two questions.
I want work for you when you're here,
so how do I reach you?
- At VaynerMedia.
We go through all our email.
- I'm also doing an interview series,
I wanted to see how I can reach out,
like, (mumbles) my friend, and--
- If you send me an email
to Gary at VaynerMedia,
the first one, I'll
put you in the process,
second one, I don't want to bullshit you,
we're trying to do less,
because I'm running out of time,
but tell me why the show is right,
and I'll take a look at it.
- Okay.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you so much.
- Good to see you.
(overlapping chattering)
- Thank you, Gary.
- Such a pleasure.
- Nice to see you again.
- It's good to see you--
- We took a, a selfie last year.
- Let's do it again.
- Thank you.
- No selfie, no time--
- Take care.
(overlapping chattering)
- Looking sharp, brother.
- I was loving those kicks, man,
by the way.
- Thank you, brother.
- I was checking them out.
- Thank you, bro.
- Yeah, yeah.
(overlapping chattering)
Yeah, we gotta do American, I
used to the Asian thumbs up.
- I know, it's a pleasure, bro.
- Yeah, man.
- Real pleasure.
Take care of yourself.
(overlapping chattering)
Hi, how are you?
- Hi.
(overlapping chattering)
- How are you, hi.
- We've been following you
for years.
- Thank you, hi, team, hi.
- [Team] Hi.
- Hi.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much.
(overlapping chattering)
- Can I have one with you?
- Please.
(overlapping chattering)
- I'm working out the
date (mumbles) for Japan.
- Thank you, I'd love
to go, I've never been.
- I'm taking care of Japan.
- I've never been.
I, there's a lot of fans there, too, so.
- Yeah, that's right.
- Thank you.
- Good?
(overlapping chattering)
- [Miles] Could you
follow me on social media?
- 100%.
- I'm gonna tag you.
I'm gonna tag you on that--
- Tag me on Instagram.
On Instagram, okay, I'll
find it, I'll do it.
(overlapping chattering)
Yes, real quick, come on,
quick, I just don't want
to get in trouble.
- Yeah, a quick one.
Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
- [DRock] Sorry, he's
got a flight to catch.
- [Gary] Turn around,
turn around, turn around.
- [DRock] Quick, quick, quick, quick.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Fan] Last question,
one more, could you?
- [Gary] Go ahead, they're
not gonna let that happen.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Assistant] He's got a flight to catch.
Sorry, guys, sorry, guys.
(overlapping chattering)
- [DRock] He cannot miss his flight, guys.
- Gary, how would you
attempt to change hearts
and mind of people whose
culture is so (mumbles)
with the pleasing and honoring
others, especially parents?
- Through action, like--
- Through action.
- Like, through action,
like, the only way to,
how do you learn how to
swim, you jump in the pool.
- Absolutely.
- When you're scared to kiss
a girl for the first time,
there's only one way to
fix it, you kiss a girl.
You don't want to disappoint your parents,
you're scared, you have
to disappoint them.
- Got it.
- The end.
Action.
- Got it, action.
Thank you, Gary.
(overlapping chattering)
- Can you do a short video,
just say something about Japan,
culturally in Japan?
(overlapping chattering)
- Japan, it's Gary Vee, I am so fired up
to finally come and give the great keynote
of our time, I've been
dying for this trip.
Japan, I will not let you down.
(overlapping chattering)
I don't know. (laughs)
They're working on it.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Maha] Somebody's doing it.
(Gary laughs)
(overlapping chattering)
- What, coming in 2029.
Japan, 2037, I'm gonna
bring the house down.
(overlapping chattering)
Sure, real quick.
Quick, quick, I'm gonna miss this flight.
(overlapping chattering)
Come on.
Thank you for your question, bro.
- [Woman In Blue Dress] I left my husband.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Gary] Once you tell
him the truth up front,
then you can do
everything, you understand?
- Hi, Gary, thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- [Man In Maroon Shirt] Thank
you, all right, thank you.
- [Gary] Awesome, take care.
- [Man In Maroon Shirt]
Thank you, have a safe trip.
- [Fan] Bye, Gary.
- [Gary] Bye, guys, thank you for coming.
(overlapping chattering)
Let's go, let's go, let's go, boys.
Walk along, walk along.
(overlapping chattering)
You guys couldn't have the cameras ready?
What the fuck, let's go.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Man In Ball Cap] Hey,
Gary, it's my birthday,
can you just wish me--
(overlapping chattering)
- Happy birthday, bro.
Let's go, let's go.
(overlapping chattering)
- Gary, I just want to
ask you one question.
- Yes.
(overlapping chattering)
- Here it is.
Okay, you know how you
told me, you told me to,
keep preaching that you have
to post content every day,
every single day, how do you start off,
how do you kickstart the content?
- You just did it.
- Like this, just this?
(overlapping chattering)
- Dude, it's all about
judgment, you can't worry
about how many likes it
gets, or what people say.
The only reason you don't
post is you're worried about
what people are gonna say.
(overlapping chattering)
Do you understand?
Let's go, real fast, let's go, fast.
(overlapping chattering)
Got it?
Got it.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Photographer] Thank
you, thank you, thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
All right.
- [Assistant] Thank you, thank you.
Flight's leaving, hurry up, guys.
(overlapping chattering)
Come on, Gary cannot miss his flight,
come on, guys.
- Thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome, guys.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Photographer] I've got
it, look at me, look at me.
- Quick one, quick one, last one.
All right, thank you, guys.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Gary] All right, guys, appreciate it.
Thank you, take care.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Fan] How do I get on your podcast?
- Listen, it's very simple,
it's Gary at VaynerMedia.
If you say something
compelling, it becomes real.
That's it, you gotta convince us.
- [Fan] Thank you.
- See you, thank you so
much, thank you, guys.
Thank you.
(overlapping chattering)
Now I can't, I've got
to get in it for a day.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [DRock] Well, if we can figure out the--
(overlapping chattering)
- I said, hey, everybody, I
said, friends, listen to me.
(speaking in foreign language)
I'm not sure how you think.
(slow electronic music)
- [DRock] What?
- I said, but I can
definitely tell you this,
DRock's a big idiot.
(group laughs)
(slow electronic music)
Actually, this Russia thing is starting
to sound exciting to me.
- [Maha] You're like, I have
kind of some good content here.
(slow electronic music)
(overlapping chattering)
- Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you,
I'm thrilled to be here.
(overlapping chattering)
Thank you.
So thank you guys so much for being here,
I'm super pumped, actually,
the only thing I'll say is,
super excited for intros,
and the one recommendation
I'll have is, I think we
should have one conversation.
One conversation is always a lot of fun
in these environments,
and it keeps it, like,
not, like, you only talk to those people.
So I will give thoughts while we,
while we go around and intro
for the opening subject matter,
and then we'll just let it ebb and flow.
(overlapping chattering)
Yeah, I don't what the,
do you have any sense of
who might or might not
come from the group?
- [Facilitator] I think we're
gonna do it to (mumbles).
- Cool, yeah, I think that's a good idea.
Yeah, awesome, we'll wait for two seconds.
For now you can do not
group conversation while we,
while we tighten it up, and
then we'll tighten it up
and get into intros, dude, that is.
All right, first question,
we're gonna go right back
around the room, Maha, so I
know you're texting somebody,
but now you have to focus.
I'm curious, so I'm unbelievably
passionate about voice
and audio, I think it's very clear to me,
like, the same patterns that
have made me successful around
what is obvious consumer
behavior, but not at scale yet,
is how I think about
Alexa and Google Home,
and whatever other competitors
they'll have globally.
But actually, I'm gonna
go slightly different,
which is, I'm curious, very
simple starting question,
do you listen to podcasts, and if you do,
what are you listening to, and
how much more do you listen
to it now than you did 24
or 36 months ago, Maha?
- [Maha] I listen daily.
- To how many things?
- [Maha] I listen to The
Daily New York Times,
every single day, it's 20
minutes, I can't miss it.
I listen to dramas, so
Blackout with Rami Malek is
really good, I listen to the
Gary, I listen to your show.
I listen to How I Built
This, and Comments by Celebs,
gotta have some entertainment in there.
- So you're consuming a ton?
- Yeah, I do.
I have it on, like, so Joe
Rogan's ones are really long,
so on the weekends, I'll put it on,
and leave it on in the
house on, like, a Saturday.
But I listen in the car, and
I listen when I work out,
and when (mumbles).
- And The New York Times
one is, like, your go-to,
'cause that's how you know
what's happening in the world?
- [Maha] Yeah, and it's also super smart,
and they bring interesting people.
It's not news, some of
it's news of the day,
but some of it's, like--
- Takes?
- [Maha] Longer form content on an issue,
you know, just, it's really interesting.
- Awesome.
- [Dinner Guest] I don't listen
to a lot of podcasts, but--
- Ever?
- [Dinner Guest] Seldom, but when I do,
it's actually for my quiet time with God.
So, like, I use it for (mumbles) church,
so that's where I actually (mumbles).
- That's really cool, okay?
- [Dinner Guest] I have
created podcasts for work.
- Good for you.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Dinner Guest] But I
actually don't listen
that much because I'm
trying to read more, so--
- Read more?
- Yeah.
So I'm not, personally I don't--
- I understand, Aves?
- [Avery] I love
podcasts, similar to Maha,
I love The Daily, Michael
Barbaro is my guy.
(overlapping chattering)
But I'm more of an audiobook listener,
actually, I love to listen to books,
especially when I'm walking
around, love a book.
And one really interesting execution
of podcasts that I think is awesome
that I think about a lot is Chompers,
if any of you guys have kids,
it's a podcast basically made
to make kids brush their
teeth, which is so fun.
But the twist is, of
course, that it's sponsored
by Crest, which I think
is really interesting,
to see how, like, and
it's downloaded a ton,
used by--
(overlapping chattering)
It's by Crest.
- Toothpaste.
- Toothpaste brand.
- [Dinner Guest] How?
- [Maha] It's a two minute podcast,
the length that a child
needs to brush their teeth
in the morning and the
evening because they can't,
parents can't get their
kids to brush their teeth,
so they make it entertaining, dragons,
monsters, they story
tell, it's really good.
- [Avery] Yeah, and
they're also launching it
in different languages very soon.
- Very cool.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Dinner Guest] I don't
listen to podcasts,
but it sounds like I'm
missing out on a lot.
(group laughs)
Sorry, I don't know. (laughs)
- [Dinner Guest] I don't
listen to podcasts so much,
the only one I listen
to is opera podcasts,
and I listen to audiobooks, for me,
it's been quite revolutionary,
because I'm not a,
I learn through hearing, so--
- Me, too.
- [Dinner Guest] So that really helped me,
the whole shift to audio, it's been like,
oh, that's so much easier.
- Me, too.
Yeah, I can't contain
information from reading at all,
to the point where, like, company emails
that are important, my reply is,
let's get on the phone for three minutes.
Like, I literally, like,
at that basic of a level,
which explains a lot for my report cards,
but, like, it's, like, in
the last couple of years,
I'm like, wow, I'm not even willing
to read four sentences from an employee.
If I can indicate from the
title or the first sentence
that it's important, I,
like, literally reply
with, like, get on the phone
with me for three minutes,
let me hear it.
- [Dinner Guest] Do you
guys use Slack, or--
- Oh, Slack's the biggest problem,
my company's only vulnerability is Slack.
(group laughs)
- [Dinner Guest] Explain that.
- I will, Slack is a
complete infrastructure
of communication in our company,
but it has 700,000
sub-Slacks for escapism.
So it's great, you know,
but the reality is,
people literally spend an
enormous amount of time
on sub, no business-related stuff.
Which is fine, like, I'm not, like,
but it's extreme.
- I see.
- Which, especially, as you can imagine,
manifests in fun conversations,
where people come to me
and say they need more team
members on their business.
And I was like, you know, if some
of your team members didn't
spend four and a half hours
on Slack bullshitting,
maybe you wouldn't need eight more people.
- [DRock] I never listen to podcasts,
I mean, I film and edit them.
(group laughs)
But I will say that over
the weekend, I did work out,
and I was listening to my
first Joe Rogan podcast.
- Ever?
- [DRock] And I was like,
I only listen to music,
and I love music, but
when I was working out,
I listened to it--
- Who, who is he?
- He was a guy (mumbles).
- Yeah, I'm getting
bombarded with that today,
and he follows me, and everybody, like,
is all about him after that interview.
- [DRock] That's good.
- Yeah.
- [Dinner Guest] Do you
generally not listen to them
because it's your work, and
you want to take a break--
- [Nerd] Yeah, I'm either
filming or listening.
- [Dinner Guest] So it's kind of like a.
(overlapping chattering)
- [DRock] Yeah.
- [Dinner Guest] Okay.
- [DRock] So I kind of just
let it go into my (mumbles).
- [Dinner Guest] Okay.
- [Dinner Guest] Yeah, I
don't do a lot of podcasts,
except listening to silence, and mainly
because when I do longer
runs, 45 minutes or.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
For me, but I like listening
to music a lot more, so.
- [Dinner Guest] I
listen to a lot of music,
but I do listen to (mumbles) podcast.
I listen to at least two
of his podcasts a week--
- At least two a week?
- Yeah.
(overlapping chattering)
And it's also 'cause when
I work, I can't listen
to somebody else speaking
while I'm doing my work, so I--
- Me neither.
- [Dinner Guest] I don't really
have much time for that, I--
- I need, I actually, when I work,
I need to listen to the
same exact song on repeat.
- [Dinner Guest] Which song is that?
- Whatever the song of
the moment is, like.
- [Dinner Guest] So does
that make the people around
you want to kill you, or?
- It's in ear, you know.
- [Dinner Guest] Only in private, yeah.
- Only private.
- [Dinner Guest] Is it the
movie soundtrack making
your whole world experience feel--
- [Dinner Guest] So you
don't get distracted, so you?
- It becomes white noise.
- [Dinner Guest] I don't
listen to podcasts.
What I do is sort of my own version of it,
and it's usually when I walk a lot.
Before living in Singapore, I guess
I walked a decent amount, and
I'll put on a YouTube video
that doesn't require me to be watching it,
so, like, I'll watch it
with the time difference.
I'll watch, like, the
opening monologue of Colbert
or something, and I'll cue it up,
stick it in my pocket, and
then that becomes my journey--
- Yep.
- [Dinner Guest] And
I'll listen to all that,
and I can sort of catch up on the stuff.
- [Dinner Guest] A lot of people do that.
- [Dinner Guest] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Dinner Guest] I have a short commute,
so I just started listening
to podcasts, (mumbles)
and yours, and (mumbles).
- Thanks for the download.
(group laughs)
- [Dinner Guest] Yeah,
I don't know, I haven't,
I'm behind the curve, I
don't listen to podcasts.
I actually do quite a bit of
reading, even outside of work,
but I can't really say I
download a lot of podcasts.
- I don't think I've ever
listened to a podcast.
I listen to you sometimes.
I've got 14 other people
in my company, and you,
what you said about the email, I don't,
I don't get more than 15, 20 emails a day,
even though I have 14 other employees.
- Wow.
- And the reason is, what you just said,
get on the phone, if
you're sending me an email,
it means I have to read
it, and you're expecting me
to respond, if you don't
expect me to respond,
where you can't make a decision,
then only send me an email.
Otherwise, emails are
not for communicating
that things are done,
or it's not information.
Email is the worst form of information,
sort of communication--
- For you.
For you, right?
- For me, for me.
- 'Cause I think that's the
important part, like, I think
so much, like, one of the
reasons I asked this question,
it's gonna build, and you
just took it there, which is,
it's just so fascinating
of, are you causing friction
for the other person?
So one thing that I've been
doing for a very long time
that more people over the last
couple years have commented
on, is I put my entire email
in the title of my email.
My entire email
(overlapping chattering)
is in the title.
- [Dinner Guest] Just one sentence, or?
- Well, whatever I have to say.
Usually less than two sentences,
'cause the way I communicate, but,
and I didn't even know why I was doing it.
I've been doing it forever, and then,
in the last year or so, or two, I'm like,
oh, I'm obsessed with eliminating friction
for the other person, it's
what I do with all my content.
It's how I think about user experience,
it's how I think about business.
So what I'm doing is, I was deploying
what would have worked for me to people
by putting everything in the title,
and now I'm on a whole array of things.
I know, I subconsciously
know who I'm calling,
I send voice memos to certain people,
I text certain people, I
write email to certain people.
I reverse engineer the,
if I have the context,
the way the person likes
to get the content,
and I think that is an
interesting insight,
where I can see a product or
a service developing where,
if you can build a product that
understands the easiest way
for me to talk, but the best way
for it to be delivered to you,
now you've got something, right?
Like, if I can just talk it,
but it comes to email for you,
'cause you're great at fucking reading,
and now for us idiots, right?
So it's interesting.
(quiet overlapping chattering)
I don't listen to anything, either, ever.
I don't consume anything,
I don't watch any shows.
I don't read anything, I literally live
my life consuming commentary on content.
Basically everything I know
comes from the comments of,
sometimes, I always use this example,
I knew more about Cardi
B before she even knew
what she looked like, or had ever listened
to a song of hers, because of commentary
on the social web about her.
That's how I consume.
- I'm a reader, although too, for,
I started listening to
podcasts because of you,
because our whole thing was, you know,
understanding how that audio is a form
of convenience, most people of
how they want to communicate.
And now the only thing
I listen to is the FT,
because they're super, actually, like,
economic structure I
find super fascinating.
Like, you talk about this a
lot, like, the shift in the '70s
to, like, shareholder
value being the only thing
that mattered, destroyed
longterm R&D, destroyed, like,
longterm, like, you know,
investment and stuff,
and I think is, like, the
root of a lot of issues.
And I find the FT interesting
because they're actually,
like, exploring a lot of other ways
of thinking about economics,
like sustainability,
and, you know, things like
that, and they're really pushing
the button in that sense.
- Thank you.
It's cool.
- But yeah, so that's all.
- [Man In Pink Shirt] I
do listen to podcasts,
exercising in the morning,
quite often yours,
get a little bit of motivation
at the start of the day.
And then probably when I go to bed.
But I don't really focus on it,
it's like a way to tune
out, to kind of relax.
- What do you listen to then?
- Not you.
(group laughs)
- So what do you?
(overlapping chattering)
- [DRock] I feel that.
- I listen to a bit of Tim Ferriss.
- Yeah, that makes sense, interesting,
that makes a lot of sense,
no, that makes a lot of sense.
- [Dinner Guest] Yeah, it does.
I'm pretty new to podcast, I
started listening maybe six
to 12 months ago, but for
me, it's more entertainment.
So I listen to more, like,
you know, true crime,
serial killers, that kind of stuff.
I don't know if that says
a bit too much about me,
but I also listen to it at the gym.
- No, it's good.
- Yeah.
- I think escapism is
foundational of happiness,
and, like, it's fun to see, like,
I just think history tells you the future,
and so you're basically
doing what people did
with radio in 1935, we
listen to entertainment.
Like that's, Serial is
soap operas on radio,
it's crazy, it's amazing, I mean,
Serial is the podcast that
started the culture movement
towards podcasts, it was the first,
podcasts had been around for a long time.
There was bubbling up in, like, '13, '14,
like, more of the kind of stuff I do,
and then it was Serial
that just swooped the US,
the UK, many other parts of the world,
where people were like,
you've gotta listen to this.
And that became the entry gateway drug
to podcasting for a lot of people.
It was a cultural phenomenon.
- [Dinner Guest] Well,
you have now Dirty John,
which was a podcast that then became a--
- A show, yeah.
- A show, and then the book,
and it's the first time
it's gone the opposite way--
- I like that maybe you--
- [Dinner Guest] And Bad
Blood, with The Dropout,
with the Theranos story
with Elizabeth Holmes,
which is a fascinating podcast, it's,
like, six episodes to listen to it,
and then they did an HBO special from it,
and all that kind of stuff--
- It's the biggest strategy we have
with Gallery Media Group, three years ago,
I bought a publishing arm
to add to our coms company,
and right now, the biggest
thing I'm doing is,
I'm doing one-off special
podcasts, four episodes,
you know, series, with
basically the main intent
for us to give us leverage
to sell the documentary.
- [Dinner Guest] Amazing.
- So literally, we're
thinking about the podcast
in the thought of,
strictly it's being created
to give leverage to own
the IP against the rights
to a documentary.
Which I think is really cool,
because I think one of the things
that has happened with
influencer marketing is
many more people can do many things.
I actually think that's what
podcasting is gonna allow.
I think there's so many amazing stories.
I'll give you an example,
this is super left field.
I have re-found my
passion for sports cards,
which was my first business as a kid,
on the back of, it's actually
happening in America,
like, it's getting popular again,
the prices are going through the roof.
So I've been doing just
enormous amounts of homework on,
what cards are under-priced, you know,
where's the arbitrage, what can I see
that other people don't?
So, for example,
I'm buying up as many
Jackie Robinson rookie cards
because I think he's a cultural icon,
and I think race and inclusion, and, like,
I think his meaning of breaking
the color barrier in the US
around baseball is gonna grown
in importance, not decline.
And so little things like that,
so this is very long-winded,
I apologize, there's a
set, on the flight here,
this is why I didn't sleep enough.
This literally happened
today, on a flight out today,
I found a 1952 set,
Wheaties, the cereal, had a set
where it wasn't cards inside,
it was on the box itself,
and people cut it,
it's called hand cut.
When I was in collecting,
it wasn't even a thing,
like, if it wasn't an official card,
it wasn't a card, but then,
like, seven years ago,
all these little weird
things that happened
through the years became
accepted as a collectible,
as a card, there's nothing on the back,
'cause usually it's just the cardboard.
It's called hand cut, I think
they're grossly under-priced,
if you just understand
basic supply and demand.
Anyway, I started studying for,
like, two hours the history
of this 1952 set, who's in it,
and something catches my eye.
It's a mix of sports, this
is 1952, and I'm like,
man, there's a lot of women in this set,
which I was excited about, I was like,
this is amazing, like, you know,
like, if you think
about, like, even today,
I don't think we have
the proper conversation
about female athletes, this is fucking,
you know, 80 years ago.
So, and then there's, I'm
like, who are these women?
So I start googling them, right?
And, like, one woman is,
like, this incredible,
like, she was the first
person to win a gold medal
in the US as a skier, so
I literally, I'm on wifi,
I'm literally, like, this
is how my brain works.
I'm like, oh, all right, so
I'm gonna buy up all her cards,
'cause they're, like, $4.00,
and there's no collectible
market for her at all,
right, you know, sports collecting,
it's usually extremely male
card, you know, like, da da da.
Like, the other average good
players from that era are,
like, 80 bucks, she's
$4.00, so I'm like, hmm.
I can buy up all her cards,
then I can do a four part
documentary series on my podcast
about this woman, then sell
Netflix the documentary,
make her a cultural icon,
which will create the demand
of her cards to go from $4.00 to $400.00.
So this is how I'm gonna
make, like, $8,000.00.
But I'm like,
(group laughs)
but I'm sorry to give you that story,
but here's where it
goes, I really got into,
like, Wikipedia, you
know, you go into stuff.
And, like, 20 minutes later,
she's an incredible woman.
I can't even imagine the
shit she probably had
to go through to get to
where, during that era,
and I was like, man, does she
have any siblings still alive?
So I literally sent it
to the editorial team,
and I was like, go find people that,
go find her granddaughters, go find, like,
you know, and, like, it's just,
there's so many stories
that are lost in history.
Like, there are obviously
the Muhammad Alis,
or the Kings (mumbles),
there are clearly the icons
that have been able to
sustain and have their story.
But if you just think
about how many all-time stories there are,
that they didn't have the
luxury of a movie being made
about them, or a documentary
being made of them.
I think, when you think about a podcast,
or a YouTube video, the cost
to tell a story continues
to decline, and I'm really excited,
'cause it really made me think, like, wow.
There's probably really
some incredible way
to unearth 1,000 icons from 50 years ago
that this last 50 years was the era
where they lost their kind of story,
and bring those stories to the forefront,
is, I think, gonna be a real opportunity.
- [Dinner Guest] And
that's what more empowering
for the audience, that these people,
you know, are not famous.
- Correct.
- [Dinner Guest] For the people
listening to it, think, oh--
- Or they've never heard it before, right?
Like, you're like, wait, she
was the most famous athlete
in the world, how did I never
hear about her, you know?
Yeah, there's a more, you can
touch it more than somebody
you've heard stories about 800 times.
- [Dinner Guest] Yeah.
- [Maha] We should go to Wheaties, Gary.
- The company?
- [Maha] Yeah, and maybe
they have some information.
- They may, they may.
Yeah, it's, it was super interesting.
What, we're done with the podcast thing?
All right, I got another one
that always plays in this.
I'm gonna start in the other direction.
What are you,
(overlapping chattering)
what are you most obsessed with?
This can be a physical
new product in your life,
this could be a Netflix
show, this could be a person,
what are you currently,
and don't, by the way,
this has gone really awry
the last couple times,
because, right, DRock, the
first three times we did it,
it was awesome.
- It was awesome.
- The last two times, it's gone very awry.
Very cool.
- [Dinner Guest] My obsession right now is
understanding stories of
just people, entrepreneurs,
and, like, what was that
starting point for them,
and just trying to, trying
to see their thought process
and where they were going.
And so it's, like, not the end idea,
but it's, like, that first idea,
and how many time that has changed
to get to where they actually were going
with what they were trying to do.
But just that, like, little unique story.
I don't need the whole long time,
but just something, the tipping point,
essentially, for them,
in whatever that is.
- Very cool.
- [Dinner Guest] I'm
obsessing over my renovation.
I have, trying to redesign this place for,
like, seven months, and I
haven't even got around to, like,
choosing the contractor.
(overlapping chattering)
Just killing me, but.
- The worst experience of
my life by a country mile,
like, was building the
Wine Library, the physical,
'cause my dad was a builder in Russia,
and loves, loves, like, building,
but doesn't want to commit
to any decision ever.
So his natural state is
to get blueprints done.
- [Dinner Guest] To plan--
- No, but this is funny, but
then be on staff as the GC,
and change everything, he
can't visualize it on paper.
So when he gets it, so we were,
we were four million dollars over-budget
on a three million dollar project,
and two and a half
years late, and I still,
like, genuinely resent my dad for it.
Like, it was the most pressure, like,
I was running the business.
I don't know if you heard me,
I'm gonna say it one more
time, four million over
on a three million project,
and two and a half years late.
When you're a small family business,
you're supposed to go out of business.
And, like, to this day,
nothing scares me anymore,
because I feel like, if I
could get through that shit.
(group laughs)
And the economy collapsed, and, like,
it was super rough, to the point where,
like, everything, like, my wife
and I bought a second home,
it was so new, it was uncomfortably new.
Like, I don't want to do anything ever,
it will never happen, I don't
want to build shit, fuck that.
- [Dinner Guest] But just turnkey, right?
- Like, triple turnkey,
like, I want you to carry me
to my home, like, I don't
want, I'm, like, so burned.
So burned, yeah, you haven't even started.
- [Dinner Guest] I haven't started.
(group laughs)
We bought the place a year ago,
we were gonna start three months later,
and then one year later, I'm still here.
I haven't even figured
out the contractor yet.
- Oh, no.
- It sucks.
- [Dinner Guest] It sucks.
- [Man Wearing Glasses] Mine is more
of a capitalistic obsession right now,
it's been going on for a
few months, I would say.
There's a company that has
operating margins of 70%,
and a net income margin of 35 or 30%.
And I'm thinking, I want
to take that company down,
there's something off, if
they're making that much,
they need competitors, so
I've been obsessing over that.
I'm been setting out--
(group laughs)
- By the way, the thesis is 100% right.
- It's like they don't have
enough competitors, or,
(overlapping chattering)
this needs to be changed, they can't.
If there's something
out there, you got to--
- And they're terrible people, right?
- They're terrible people.
(group laughs)
They are.
- I just think every, I just, amazing.
- [Man Wearing Glasses] So
if you don't jump in there,
you're wasting your time.
- Any wine?
- [Man Wearing Glasses] No wine, please.
- [Man In Pink Shirt] And
the name of that company?
(group laughs)
- It's too important to keep.
- [Man Wearing Glasses] No,
no, no, it's not, it's Axon.
- Axon?
- The taser, body camera manufacturers.
(overlapping chattering)
So, so with that said, I
have launched a company,
which actually, Gary, thanks to you,
two of the investors were,
I met them over here.
- That's awesome.
- [Man Wearing Glasses] So one is.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
- I love it.
(overlapping chattering)
- Government Ministry of
Defense, the other investor,
and 500 startups.
- No shit, that's awesome.
- [Man Wearing Glasses] So if
you recall, they were the--
- Yes, I recall, I recall.
- [Man Wearing Glasses] And so they went,
when I, six months back, I'm like--
- Axon?
- [Man Wearing Glasses] Yeah.
- Axon.
- [Man Wearing Glasses]
They're the manufacturer.
And they're about three,
four billion market cap,
and I'm just kind of obsessed, like,
they need to be taken down.
(group laughs)
This is--
- What's your company called, Ax-off?
(group laughs)
- It's Seven Cents.
- Seven Cents, that's
awesome, bro, my obsession is
a really interesting one,
'cause it's been around for a while,
and it also is the one thing
the company has done well
in eight years, I genuinely believe
that Apple has been one
of the worst run companies
for the last eight years by a big margin.
And that Tim Cook will go down
as an all-time terrible CEO
because everyone will blame
him for the demise of Apple
because he's completely
mis-strategized this whole era,
and just basically has milked everything
that was done before him in his quest
to be considered a good human,
which I think is amazingly noble.
And I love that, white, please.
So I like him very much for
what he stands for as a human,
and I hate him as an executive,
but my EarPods are my favorite obsession
because I'm just blown away
by how great that product is.
It is, all the seconds that
that product saves me every
single day is a very big deal
for me, like, anything that
saves me time is my number one.
And I, like, what happened, oh.
I was, like, why am I saying this?
Because I've been so hot on it, my pair,
you notice, my black ones
are gone, like, my pair,
something happened, I
don't know what happened,
but they just stopped working.
And in that day and a half of traveling
and, like, I didn't lose
them, it was just in that,
they weren't working, so
in that day and a half
where I didn't have them,
and I had to use it normal,
it, like, blew me away, how much friction
that was, in comparison to having them,
which makes you appreciate
things, obviously.
So that is my current obsession.
- Honestly, this is, the first thing
that came to mind was
anime, I think, like,
it's because, like--
- It's a great thing.
- Yeah, I mean, we've been so
heads down with everything,
and, you know, when you say escapism,
like, I don't watch any
television, I don't watch,
like, but I love anime, and
it's also just fascinating
because, from a story perspective--
- It's so good.
- It's crazy.
It's, like, war, and
power, and, like, insanity,
and, like, things that you, like,
would read in a Russian novel, but, like,
you know, with crazy,
cutesy little characters.
And the most, and, that, like,
if you want any
recommendations, I've been,
like, bombing through some great series--
- Where are you, what
are you consuming it on?
- Netflix, Netflix going into
anime was fricking genius,
and now they're doing their
own stuff, that, like--
- [Dinner Guest] Yeah,
they're doing their own thing.
- So clever.
- That's their entire
model, overpay for IP
that gets you in, leverage the eyeballs
to the stuff they own.
- Yeah.
- [Man In Pink Shirt] I was struggling,
'cause I think my current obsession,
and it would be the EarPods
if I could keep them.
I always lose them, like, I've got--
- [Gary] Really?
- [Man In Pink Shirt] 20 pairs (mumbles).
- Seriously?
(overlapping chattering)
It's amazing how much I don't lose shit.
- [Man In Pink Shirt] It's so frustrating
to go back to the normal
ones, so I feel that, that--
- You mean, like, the wires?
- [Man In Pink Shirt]
Yeah, it's frustrating,
but it's, I keep losing the bloody cords.
But my current obsession
is the next three years
of Vinner, we're in a really
kind of interesting time.
- How old is your company?
- Just over eight years.
- [Dinner Guest] Wow.
- [Man In Pink Shirt] Yeah, but it's,
we're in a really interesting phase--
- [Gary] Good for you.
- [Man In Pink Shirt] Really
exciting, but it's all
in the kind of three year
strategy phase at the moment,
and then there's a lot
of thought, there's a lot
of kind of branding work,
yeah, it's interesting.
- That's awesome.
- [Dinner Guest] Sorry.
(background noise drowns out speaker)
I actually have my own
communications company,
and that would be my current
obsession at the moment.
It's still very much a baby,
it's about 18 months old.
So my obsession is very
much about how to grow it,
how to do things better, how to, you know,
develop a team, but then
also, at the same time,
how to give myself more work life balance,
how to not be so stressed all the time,
how to sleep better, and
all that kind of stuff.
So it's constantly just
going and going and going.
- I get it.
- [Maha] I have so many things, I'm just--
- I'm sorry, you're
gonna have to pick one.
(group laughs)
- [Maha] I'm obsessed
with, so I have a niece
and nephew who live in the States,
and I'm obsessed with
connecting with them,
helping them, being there
for them, talking to them,
sharing with them, like, not
to stress out about everything,
and how to, they're going through a,
they're teenagers,
they're on social media,
a lot of pressure at school,
all that kind of stuff,
transitions to high school,
transition to college.
And I'm obsessed with, like,
them being the best humans
they can be, and how
can I use my successes
and failures to be there for them.
- That's awesome.
- It's just--
- [Dinner Guest] How often do
you get in touch with them?
- [Maha] Daily.
- [Dinner Guest] Wow.
- Yeah, they're very close.
- [Maha] I talk to them
daily, my sister lives
in the States--
- They're so close that
somebody, I apologize,
Maha, but this is just to, like,
give an indication to the room,
somebody in the office was
just like, "What's Maha about?"
Like, her, literally, that,
my answer started with,
"Her relationship with her niece
"and nephew is a good starting point."
Like, it's, like, the biggest thing,
it's the biggest thing I think about
when I think about you, that's,
like, the first thing I think.
I know how that, it's really interesting,
which is unusual, like.
- And it just grows.
Like, I just feel like I
have to do everything I can,
and I love spending time with them.
- [Man Wearing Glasses]
Is this a cultural thing,
like, in the community,
is it that way, or?
- [Maha] You know, I'm Egyptian, so,
I mean, I think they're
just, like, I'm Auntie Maha,
and they're just, like,
but all of their friends
in high school follow me on
Snapchat and talk to me daily.
All of their friends, like in high school,
they wanted to me to give the speech
to the graduating class--
- That's awesome.
(overlapping chattering)
They couldn't afford you?
(group laughs)
- [Maha] All the parents are,
like, "You're Auntie Maha?"
Like, I'm, like, I feel like--
- You're like a meme?
- [Maha] Yeah, and I like that avenue
where they can talk to me, I can talk,
and then the moms are like,
"What are the boys doing?"
I'm like, "I'm not telling you," like,
I want them to feel bad, and so--
- That's cool.
- [Maha] That's my obsession.
- [Dinner Guest] Is it always visual
when you are interacting with
them, is it FaceTime, or--
- [Maha] No, I Snapchat,
and I VoiceNote them.
And they always reach
out to me, but, like,
I have my niece and
all of her girlfriends,
it's prom tomorrow night, and I have--
- Shit's going down.
(overlapping chattering)
- [Maha] Who, you know, now follow Gary,
they learn all about entrepreneurship,
so they're learning, so
I'm trying to educate them.
Like, this is what you
guys should be following,
these are some, like,
their parents are grateful,
'cause I'm trying to at
least help them see things
that they wouldn't normally see.
- That's awesome.
- [Maha] So that's my obsession.
- [Dinner Guest] My obsession
right now is actually
with the Kardashians.
- Oh my god, so good.
- [Dinner Guest] So I
really think of them as.
- Maybe Tuesdays could
work, I'm sure (mumbles)
they could create, you know,
so people would show up.
But the question for me is more, like,
I feel like there's an increasing need
to have moments where there's no tech.
So, you know, like I say,
when you create rules,
or you create frameworks,
and you set things clearly,
like, what this space is for,
and the more restrictions
you have, the more--
- Powerful.
- The community, and the more
sticky the community becomes--
- Yeah, I agree.
- So--
- You're saying that's a layer, listen,
I think it's a great thought.
(slow electronic music)
- [Chatri] The Jets, and all that stuff?
- I sure am, I sure am.
- [DRock] You got a date,
you got a date on that?
- I'd love to pull it off, what am I, 43?
I'd love to pull it off in 22 years.
Like, I'm, I'm basically holding
my breath the whole way
through, I'm not extracting--
- The journey is--
- It's so much better.
- 'Cause what you do--
- I don't think I--
- He's gonna crash, like,
that's the thing is,
like, even, like, for me, like,
this ONE Champ thing is like,
I started seven and a half years ago,
and it's gone ballistic, and, like,
I've been trying to enjoy the
journey, and everyone's like,
oh, man, you're gonna
be bigger than the NFL.
But I just, the day that happens, I'm not,
like, it's not,
it's the journey.
- It's the journey.
- Yeah, it's the dream, the
dreaming keeps you going--
- You either like the
process, or you don't.
- Yes, exactly.
- Too many people want, this is the reason
we have such a fucked up
entrepreneurial ecosystem as,
you know, people in this room
that all are executing
different things, like,
if you genuinely are building a business
for the flip to take the money
and do douche bag things,
you're just a broken framework.
- I totally agree.
- Like, you're a broken
framework, you're, like,
if your entire life is predicated on,
how do I get the VC money,
and what bigger company do
I sell it to, so that I
can then take that money,
and get a boat, and go to fucking Mykonos,
and go fucking get the fucking
biggest setup at Burning Man,
and, like, do all that shit,
you're gonna fucking lose.
- Yeah, 'cause--
- You're broken.
You're so insecure and so
not in love with your process
that your ability to actually
pull it off becomes so,
so minimal.
- I totally agree.
I was just telling Raj,
right, the first three years,
my partner and I, we
lost 50 million dollars
of our own money, zero
revenues, no TV ratings,
no metrics, no distribution, nothing.
And we're throwing this shit,
and nothing was happening.
But what kept us was,
I believed, and I was--
- [Gary] Lost five zero, you said?
- 50, between me and my partner.
- [Gary] You guys, from prior businesses,
or raised capital, or?
- We were both independently
wealthy before this,
and then we both plowed
everything into this,
and just kept on losing money,
kept on losing money, and just bombing,
and nothing was happening,
and then year four,
five, six, seven, just, we went--
- What happened, give me,
a lot of things happened.
Is there any, was there an athlete
that caught the attention of everybody?
- [Chatri] No, but there's a few things,
right, so--
- Was there an upset?
Was there a match?
- Right, so.
Well, first of all--
- 'Cause what's so cool, right,
like, I apologize for interrupting,
you brought it up twice now,
there is a signature NFL game,
an overtime game between the Colts
and the New York Giants that
was aired on television,
which was a new technology at the time,
that changed the NFL.
The NFL was so unpopular
compared to college football,
you couldn't imagine.
Nobody gave a fuck.
- [DRock] Was that, right, right.
- 'Cause Super Bowl One didn't sell out.
- [DRock] Yeah, yeah, when was that--
- In 1967, that was the
NFL championship game.
I think that was 1958,
I think, I'm guessing now,
'cause I know DRock's filming now,
so I won't go with conviction.
But it was, I think it
was, like, '58, Super Bowl,
and it was live on TV, and
it was an overtime game,
and everybody got sucked into the drama,
what's amazing about
sports, and that was it.
The sport was never to be the same.
- Exactly, so it's kind
of funny, 'cause, like,
in seven and a half years,
we're now bigger than F1
in all the metrics, just
because of technology,
social media--
- Of course.
- Virality of content,
and all that technology,
you know, I was thinking about, like,
Bernie Ecclestone's whole
journey with F1, 1950 he started.
He had to go brick by, country by country,
city by city, car by car,
it was like, insane, right?
- [Gary] Scale.
- Here--
- It's, exactly, so what
happened with us was pure luck.
In Asia, the last five years,
mobile devices took off,
social media took off,
our content happened
to be short form, exciting, entertaining.
And no one's gonna watch
a 90 minute soccer game,
you know, where you can't
see the ball on your mobile,
no one's gonna see a basketball game and,
and everything they, but
you'll watch two guys go at it
for two minutes--
- Do you know
that this is my biggest
thesis about sports?
In America, which is what I can speak to,
radio was the number one
medium, and for that reason,
boxing, ironically, fighting, horseracing,
and baseball were sports
that people could imagine,
where football struggled in comparison,
basketball struggled, when
television came along,
football was made for television.
And so what's interesting
to what you were saying,
and I couldn't agree
with you more, I mean,
I don't think people understand
how rawly human two men fighting is.
If me and DRock decided to fight right now
and livestream it, it would
be my most viral content.
Forget about people
knowing, forget about even,
actually, if I filmed two people
that nobody even knows right now fighting,
like, people don't know
how deeply human that is.
You know what else is actually that way
that I can't stop thinking about?
I'm thinking about starting
the national racing league,
there's, and I mean foot racing.
There's an inherent, raw,
every six-year-old's like,
I'll race you, like, I
think the amount of people
that would watch two random
people race each other
and bet on it is enormous.
- [Chatri] Well, here's the thing, right--
(quiet overlapping chattering)
When I started--
- But it's head to head.
- When I started ONE Championship,
okay, I lit up all the sports
around the world, okay?
And I've been doing martial
arts for 36 years, I--
- [Gary] You're passionate.
- This is my--
- [Gary] You do it, you love it.
- I was doing it, professional fighter,
coach, everything, I've done everything.
And I laid it down, and I said, okay,
socioeconomic on one axis,
okay, rich man, poor man--
- [Gary] Love.
- Or woman, whatever it is, tennis, golf,
da da, that can't scale,
soccer can scale, okay?
Because it's simple, you
don't need to explain
to anybody, there's no
rules, it's just literally--
- [Gary] It also is not expensive
to start when you're young.
- Exactly, and then,
(overlapping chattering)
then the horizontal axis is,
American football amasses
for 80 billion dollar property in America,
but American football does not transfer--
- [Gary] Only America, nowhere else.
- Nowhere else--
- Nowhere else
- There's only two sports,
and now you say foot racing,
that's another potential,
there are only two sports
in the world that have this,
it is exactly what Gary said,
soccer, easy to understand,
and fighting, so for--
- The one, the emerging one is basketball,
the emerging one, if you
look at the same data,
and I'm looking at the same thing, it's,
basketball is unbelievably global.
It's, I'm so impressed by it.
- [Chatri] Well, like.
- Good seeing you, all
the best, good trip.
- [Chatri] Nice to meet you, brother.
- Congrats, bro.
- [Chatri] We should hang out.
- Yeah, real proud of you, bro.
- [Chatri] Thanks--
- [Gary] It's really
fucking awesome, really.
(overlapping chattering)
(slow electronic music)